hey friends this is a special crossover
episode with my friend kurt jaimungle
and lee cronin uh kurt janmungle runs
the youtube channel called theories of
everything you should check it out i've
been a guest there once before and he
interviews some of the same cast of
characters that you'll find on my
channel but he does so with his own
unique inveterate reportive type
perspective he's really truly pretty
naturally gifted
at this game of long form i'm talking
super long form our interview which
you're about to watch uh is over two and
a half hours long and that's one of his
shorter episodes he likes to go deep
kind of in the spirit of alex friedman
or joe rogan and he gets into the heart
of the issue he tends to cover things uh
that i do not in some ways he who likes
to go deep into
perspectives of whether or not there is
actual evidence for life in the universe
of an alien origin and so if you're
interested in those things of ufos uaps
and so forth please do check out his
channel there'll be a link in the video
description below and i commend it to
your attention and your affection
because he is one of the best in the
business and he's also a great friend
and this episode is with my friend lee
cronin we're talking about the basics of
life
of life in the universe which i claim to
be rare it's kind of a debate between me
and lee lee thinks life is abundant
ubiquitous and we're just one
instantiation thereof i bring a
different perspective as you'll hear i
hope you'll enjoy it we took audience
questions from kurt's audience
as well as uh from folks on twitter and
elsewhere and uh we're promised maybe a
part two you'll see
kurt calls this round one so look
forward to round two we go toe to toe
theory of everything to theory of
everything life the universe and
everything so i hope you enjoy this
episode of into the impossible crossed
over from kurt j mungle's wonderful
theories of everything uh youtube
channel check it out
this was recorded on january 19th 2022
brian keating is a distinguished
professor of physics at the university
of california san diego and is also a
member of avilob's galileo project
assisting for the search for alien
techno signatures across the cosmos
brian also has his own podcast exploring
physics from the theoretical end to the
experimental end and he has the record
of interviewing the most nobel laureates
links to his podcast are in the
description lee cronin is the regis
chair of chemistry in the university of
glasgow and in addition to having a
velvety accent that i highly covet he's
published over 450 papers and pioneered
a new quantitative measure of complexity
called assembly theory this allows one
to look at a molecule and categorize its
complexity perhaps even with mass
spectrometry and then determine if it's
sufficiently complicated enough to have
been produced solely as a result of an
evolutionary process or by chance but
you can measure that and thus that
greatly aids the search for life outside
of earth click on the time stamp in the
description if you'd like to skip this
intro my name is kirchey mungle i'm a
torontonian filmmaker with a background
in mathematical physics dedicated to the
explication of the variegated terrain of
theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as analyzing consciousness and
seeing its potential connection to
fundamental reality whatever that is
essentially this channel is dedicated to
exploring the underrived nature of
reality the constitutional laws that
govern it provided those laws exist at
all and are even noble to us if you
enjoy witnessing and engaging with
others on the topics of psychology
consciousness physics etc the channel's
themes then do consider going to the
discord and the subreddit which are
linked in the description there's also a
link to the patreon that is patreon.com
kirchimongo if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reasons that i'm
able to have podcasts of this quality
and this depth given that i can do this
now full time thanks to both the patrons
and the sponsors support speaking of
sponsors there are two the first sponsor
is brilliant during the winter break i
decided to brush up on some of the
fundamentals of physics particularly
with regard to information theory as i'd
like to interview chiara marletto on
constructor theory which is heavily
based in information theory now
information theory is predicated on
entropy at least there's a fundamental
formula for entropy so i ended up taking
the brilliant course i challenged myself
to do one lesson per day and i took the
course's random variable distributions
and knowledge slash uncertainty what i
loved is that despite knowing the
formula for entropy which is essentially
hammered into you as an undergraduate it
seems like it comes down from the sky
arbitrarily and with brilliance for the
first time i was able to see how the
formula for entropy which you're seeing
right now is actually extremely natural
and it'd be strange to define it in any
other manner there are plenty of courses
and you can even learn group theory
which is what's being referenced when
you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su-2 cross su-3
those are league groups continuously
groups visit
brilliant.org tow t-o-e to get 20 off an
annual subscription and i recommend that
you don't stop before four lessons i
think you'll be greatly surprised at the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking the second sponsor is algo
now algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce return and
inventory write downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since near its inception in
fact amjad has his own podcast on ai and
consciousness and business growth and if
you'd like to support the tow podcast
then visit the link in the description
to see amjad's podcast because
subscribing to him or at least visiting
supports the toe podcast indirectly
thank you and enjoy is that an aura ring
i got mine here i got i joked this one
you see this one
no
that's the fourth generation it's
stealth
oh i get it
do you have any words for me before we
go live by the way any of you
um just no i mean i think we can make it
kind of funny and you know say we're
gonna brian
you say brian is in denial about his
alien abduction
[Laughter]
we'll say we'll have a nice clean toe to
toe fight
you're gonna have a theory of everything
verse theory of everything
life the universe and everything
okay so if you can see this type rocco's
modern life
broncos modern life
this should be live now
brian you can confirm that for me
um
yes it is
all right yeah
okay great thank you thank you all for
being here to the audience and to
especially to professor keating and
professor cronin thank you
it's a pleasure to be here good to see
you lee
yeah hi how's it going guys
how about you both start with your
opening statements brian you can go
first
okay well first of all uh i'm wishing uh
that this will be a nice clean
toe-to-toe
battle uh that we won't resort to any
bloodshed like our last uh confrontation
with no lee elia's been on my channel
he's a gracious gentleman i enjoyed
having him on i refer people to uh to
check out that conversation he's given a
ted talk that was uh surely
inspirational that came out 10 years ago
on my 40th birthday so you guys can do
some quick math um and league hasn't
changed a bit i've got some some gray
beard hairs as you can see um but the
reason i i suggest kurt said you know
you can have any guests
you know to have a theo locution
which is appropriate for gods like us
um in in man form and i said uh there's
no one i want to go toe-to-toe with more
than my good friend lee cronin because i
have tremendous respect for his
intellect uh for his character for the
fact that he's an experimentalist he's a
chemist not a physicist but he that's
okay some of my best friends are
chemists and uh he does experimental
work and that's very rare kurt as you
know you have theories in your name of
your podcast we hear a lot more from the
theorists we hear from michio kaku from
our buddy eric weinstein from our
buddies you know brian green and and uh
all the like but we rarely get to hear
from experimentalists so one of the
niches i like to hopefully fill in
um is is to bring an experimentalist
standpoint to it which is first and
foremost driven by evidence
and i'm hoping that today uh if lee
agrees that we'll kind of take a tour
through what we know about the universe
what we know we don't know about the
universe specifically restricted to life
which is lee's domain much more than
mine
but i want to bring an experimental
observational astrophysics perspective
to things and even touch upon the things
that inspired me as a 12 year old kid to
get my first telescope which is the
biggest question i think there is even
though i study the origin of the
universe i still think the question of
the origin and evolution of life and the
existence of technological life would
change humanity more than anything else
except for the fact that i don't think
there's anyone else out there so i'm
going to take a contrarian point of view
not a skeptic i don't like the role of
skeptic i think that's kind of overblown
and hyperbolic um and people you don't
want to invite too many skeptics to uh
you know to a fun birthday party but i
want to play to play the role of uh of
somebody who would like nothing better
than for aliens for ufos for uaps to all
be harbingers of unexplored
civilizations that are going to be
hopefully benevolent
and yet i'm coming to from a perspective
of moderation of my excitement so that i
don't get too overblown and too
optimistic and i hope that we can have a
a very spirited discussion and as i said
there's no one i'd rather have this
friendly bloodthirsty debate with than
uh professor lee cronin who's a who's a
giant in his field and has already
accomplished a tremendous amount and yet
we differ and and hopefully by the end
we should have a rubric by which we can
apprise for the audience how much we
have learned from each other if i change
my mind if lee changes his mind so maybe
after lee's introduction we'll have kind
of a framing you know the rules of the
fight like kurt you'll be in the middle
of the ring and we'll go toe to toe with
that turn it over to my buddy lee
lee thanks brian is that okay were you
cut yes please go so yeah i mean this is
i was really looking forward to this
because uh brian and i both shared a
rule of scientific law that um we kind
of like data and we like experiments and
we like theory and
um i've listened to brian debate a lot
and he's very poli he's much more polite
and patient than i am so i have a lot of
respect i really have to read between
the lines and i've been involved in some
debates where people just want to catch
me out
and i and i'm no doubt brian's been in
the same place so i would say today is
probably almost going to be too
congenial but i think that's really
important because
we're both open-minded but we're
optimistic about different things now as
a chemist
i have a very
intuitive feel for the way chemistry
works on planet earth the rate at which
molecules are made and destroyed
and i'm fascinated by biology and
and actually i'm gonna i describe myself
for full um
disclosure i'm really an experimental
theorist in a way i'm not
i don't think i have the
analytical um brain to be a good
theorist but i'm really good at coming
up with
experiments to develop a theory and i'll
explain a little bit seems a bit weird
but um
i do agree with brian i'm very skeptical
about making declarations i i don't
know if i can put a number on and i was
on my computer on about alien life or
not i wrote a paper a few years ago
which is called um
uh quantifying the origins of life on a
planetary scale and i'll talk about the
drake equation and the fermi paradox and
the chemistry but let's let and i also
want to make this about what brian is
doing very well is saying hey i don't i
don't
know or i'm not i won't paraphrase too
much because i think he's much more
qualified to give his own point of view
given he's here so there is this kind of
gap in his intuition
and i'm going to try and fill that and
say well look i know how easy chemistry
is
i know how odd life is
and i want to make a couple of
statements the first thing is we don't
really know what life is and i don't
mean in some kind of weird kind of um
whether we are you know um projections
from an astral plane we're clearly
material i'm i'm kind of a materialist
but to kind of ch cheat on one of a copy
of what penrose said in a podcast said
i'm a materialist but i just don't know
what the matter is
right and i think that's kind of
important to understand that so that's
one point the other point is i would
appeal to at this house at the beginning
i would say there's lots of gaps
in my kind of feeling of how the
universe works so physicists typically
have i think not
not have three or four things that they
i find confusing that they conflate to
kind of think that life is odd the first
of all is the origin of the universe how
did the universe get started you'll hear
time and time again for the second law
that is that things get more disordered
over time we have more order at the
beginning so say hey where does that
order come from and brian is really well
qualified to
explain that and i'm hoping that by him
explaining some of the positions i find
confusing
i'll be able to explain some of the
positions he finds confusing we might
even find ourselves agreeing which is
not a very good blood spore but let's
let's not prejudge our agreement because
there's lots of disagreement so
physicists think that there needs to be
a um an order at the beginning of the
universe so i find that confusing
and i
the second law for me is baked into the
way i do chemistry so i get this
chemistry all these complex molecules
and they turn into life and hey presto
we get there well actually it's not like
that we don't know what it is
the other gap is that we talk about this
thing called entropy
and we also talk about what we call
causation and kind of the emergence of
information or intention and so in my
opening statement i would just like to
say there are significant gaps in
physics which help us which we're
precluded from really even understanding
why the universe is here so i both
sympathize with brian's view
but i also would like to go you know
straight back at you and say could we
could
understanding the origin of life which
i'm not so interested in i want to
understand how life forms is a phenomena
um it might even actually help us
understand what the universe is
and so my
real
intuition is that
life is as easy as starting a fusion
reaction in the sky
and there are fusion reactions starting
all the time stars giving birth and
stars dying
and we need to think statistically in
that way to start to reframe the
argument now
does all life turn into intelligent life
we can debate that and talk about it but
i would say that in my opening argument
i think i see no barrier for why life
can't be common there seems to be no law
or no
gotcha in terms of resource
but i do concede we don't know what life
is but i also would kind of say you know
we don't really know how
where
the second law comes from
that we time seems to be optional in our
universe
and we have all this jiggery pokery with
the second law and how things happen and
uh and with that i will close my opening
statement
all right let's agree on some
definitions or let's get them out of the
way so perhaps lee why don't you define
i know this is highly contentious but
why don't you define what life is and if
you can't define it then why can't you
define it and then also intelligence so
life and intelligence and then brian
add to that or tear it down
yeah please tear it down so there's more
definitions of life than there are life
forms on earth thinking about it
which will give you some but i'll give
you the standard nasa definition and
i'll give you a slightly easier one
which will also blow your mind so nasa
kind of got a committee and got a lot of
really smart people together and really
you know say well okay look what are we
kind of looking for
and i'm going to get this wrong because
i i i don't know if i
wrote but it's roughly saying that life
is a
self um reproducing or a sustaining
um um
evolutionary chemical system capable of
darwinian evolution i think i've almost
got it in a line and that's there's a
lot of things in there because it's
saying has to be self-sustaining there's
replication and there's darwinian
evolution there's a kind of a lot of
terms
and the thing for that is that you have
to then get almost like the legislature
out to say you know do you qualify to be
a life form you know are you replicating
okay maybe are you metabolizing and then
you get people saying oh but fire fire
fire kind of does that why is fire not
alive and you get all trapped into
circles and people say are viruses are
they alive so i'm going to give you um
the kind of cronin
definition but actually is the probably
more like the walker definition or the
cronin walker definition and i'm i'm
collaborating with a
a colleague at asu sarah walker um who
really has inspired a lot of this and we
kind of we've been developing theory but
i'll come to that later but what i'm
going to say and this is for you the
people listening
that
living systems i don't know what they
are exactly they're kind of like a bit
although they're material there's some
weird stuff but what do living systems
uniquely do that no other systems do
they create
complex objects
okay
in abundance that couldn't form randomly
so be it this 3d printer tesseract which
i made on my 3d printer
um this nice um
fenix
solar watch which are the lights coming
on at the back so it's all function and
my mouse and my my body and the complex
objects that um they just couldn't
randomly form now we can define
complexity in a minute but i'm going to
give you kind of one other thing
this thing or kind of says that this is
alive and it kind of is which will blow
your mind this is this is alive
or this is evidence of life and then
people say ah a virus is alive
and the answer is yes viruses are
produced by
um uh evolutionary systems with biology
and that viruses could not
exist without
the chain of events which connects all
of us
right back to that origin of life on
earth so i guess i'm saying that's the
definition
for some of the aficionados that
you know replication metabolism
darwinian evolution
but i would say okay that's really hard
tick box tick box why not look for
things that do complex things that we
wouldn't expect
and so that's life
to one degree then intelligence kind of
builds on that because clearly
this was not evolved in in the desert
this required human beings to invent
you know
lithography a turing machine electricity
i mean i am so proud of humanity it
might sound a bit like a bit kind of um
you know
weird but
how much creativity went into making
this silly little watch there's a solar
cell in here there are leds there's a
microprocessor there's lithographic
defined memory and there's refined
titanium i was feeling rich when i
bought when i bought this but i wanted a
light watch on my list there's all this
cool stuff that we've done and this
clearly is evidence and i'm going to use
this term and i don't like using it but
i'm going to use it in the way that i
mean it and i'm sure brian will and you
will cut me down if you think i'm being
uh ambiguous this is a result of
intelligent design
and what i mean a human being building
abstractions in their head were able to
leap beyond the confines of evolution
able to think about stuff and
conceptualize not having to die trying
it out and they made the watch so
all the way back definition of life
evolution chemistry
nasa my definition stuff
things that make complex things you
couldn't uh in abundance with lots of
copy numbers that you wouldn't find
um ordinarily let's say on the moon on
the mars and
intelligent life can make objects are
even more intricate so you have three
epochs you have the random epoch just
laws of physics doing their cool stuff
the biological epoch the distribution of
objects in that in their narrows a bit
and then
and then technology and intelligence
produces a delta function
the number of transistors in here that
have no variation almost perfect is a
staggering and that's kind of
long-winded but i think i just wanted to
get that out it's quite precise and
we'll get people watching and listening
to think really like oh my gosh this cup
is evidence of billion years of life
because with no potter no discovery of
no clay no cup just imagine how this
this lineage this trajectory this object
this is actually made in beijing there's
some lovely pictures on here
this is evidence of billions of years of
progress
i'll stop there brian what are your
comments on that
well yeah you know of course with the
definition as
maybe one could say flexible as
all that could you know be said to
entail of course there's there's uh it's
hard to disagree
i was preferring to think about things
you know there was a decision you you
you both are not of the united states in
origin uh but there was a famous supreme
court case in the 50s i think where the
court was asked to describe what is
pornographic
and the upshot was that you know it when
you see it and i think you know we can
we can kind of uh you know debate about
things that we know for sure aren't
alive and we can debate about things
that we could all say are alive and i
think leads on to something that there
may be a deep and
maybe unassailable
interplay between the uh notion of the
conscious being that's defining life
and the order and structure uh by which
he or she ascribes that feature to be
indicative of a biological process
um normally what i hear is well life it
depends and even what is consciousness
it depends and as you know kirk there
are people that believe you know the
quarks in the cup that lee was holding
up are a lot or have consciousness in a
pan psychist format i don't know if lee
believes that or not uh but uh but i i
would suspect not yes he's shaking his
head so i think uh what i think is
important is that we all sort of can
recognize the boundary cases um as not
or or yes certainly affirming to be of
life and it's kind of like you know
these debates about you know uh like
think about abortion abortion's really
controversial here in america um nobody
would say before your parents met each
other uh that you were an organism you
were a baby and nobody would say after
you know 10 months out of the womb that
you're not a living being so it's in the
it's in the superposition the
schrodinger state where it can be is it
alive is it that's where the ambiguity
comes in and the human brain is leak
knows and you know too uh kurt
hates ambiguity we force patterns on top
of things the ambiguity bias is a
well-known psychological affair so the
question is not are the edge cases alive
um
but are the you know how do we how do we
parse and split with granularity that's
sufficient to provide the satisfaction
morally and intellectually that we're
actually making progress so i like that
lee began or you know uh originally he
mentioned the drake equation
and we should we should actually go
through that and what that entails
because i think in that realm my field
not me specifically i don't study the
origin of life or technology et cetera
it has has brought the most to bear
the field of astrophysics again not what
i do but the many terms in the drake
equation have been reduced in their
uncertainty has come from astrophysics
not from chemistry not from biology et
cetera you know from discoveries that
have been made by my colleagues not by
me again so i think what's what's
important is that we we all can first
agree on the baseline definitions on the
pitch
which is that you know living things we
we have some vague notion of what living
things are and i think the only thing i
was a little discouraged and what lee
said originally was he doesn't want to
talk about the origin of life and i feel
like all these things are kind of
interrelated they're a classic chicken
or egg type problems you know and and i
think
life chemistry etc has has a great deal
to say and i'm i'm doubly surprised
because in leigh's phenomenal ted talk
from 2011 september 9 2011 my 40th
birthday
uh he goes on and tells chris anderson
in front of a live audience that within
two years he's going to be able to make
life in his laboratory and i don't think
necessarily that you would claim that to
be a successful bet at this point lee
but i'd love to know what what is and
i'm not criticizing you
merely bringing up the fact that there
is a tendency mostly in my field to have
things like the god equation the god
particle
the mind of god and the god
all these things the hype that we have
in the field of cosmology kurt is
unparalleled
and i worry
that if we um if we don't avoid that in
kind of the essence of describing the
origin of life evolution of life aliens
ufos all the things we're going to talk
about today i hope we will because it's
so fascinating and has driven me since i
was a kid
nevertheless there is a tendency and a
propensity for us to believe what we
want to believe and maybe put things in
the file drawer that we find discrepant
and so
i would just say i think it is important
that we talk about the origin of life i
think that's a crucial question and i
think there's no one better on earth to
talk to than lee
i'm sure there are many better people to
talk to let's unpack it then unpack it
so yeah the ted talk i really enjoyed
doing the ted talk i was the first staff
at the
ted global that year the first start
from the start of origins um i actually
meant what i meant
i mean what i said in full and it sounds
like a cop-out politician you know you
know boris johnson's like i didn't know
it was a party um i i i made so what i
was trying to make is two important
points and number one is that uh that i
think the origin of life is fast
and once i've worked out how to set up
the engine i'm building a uh
evolutionary engine it will take a
couple of years i stand by that
and it has been two years it's been 10
years but in the 10 years i've had to
design a programming language for
chemistry in lab and find the money and
when i went to get money from people and
i said hey guys do you want to invest in
the origin of life their eyes glaze over
and they said and i said okay
do you want to invest in drug discovery
oh yeah good so what i've been doing
over the years is actually building this
technology now exists in the lab and i'm
super excited
now i made a major error
many major errors i mean i completely
concede i wasn't over hyping saying it
was j you can watch a video i was
generally like i wasn't expecting that
question i was like i don't know two
years why not that's cool let's let's go
um
um but
there's there's a really important point
that um at that point i had an intuition
um about what what to look for but i
didn't really have an experiment okay
um i didn't have a theory
i didn't have a model
and i didn't have a threshold and i was
like
can i swear on on air i was like yeah
what do you mean by threshold you didn't
have a threshold i'll come to that in a
second so i was like holy [ __ ] i have
nothing
right and then you think then i looked
at cern and how they did it so nasa's
nasa couldn't find the origin of life
that oh sorry alien other life dependent
on it because they're like oh is it is
it green is it a micro tube is it being
is it actually to be fair nasa didn't
say anything about phosphine we'll come
to that but inspired by the machine that
is was the lhc
they have the one of the best press
officers ever
they had the standard model it's a
beautiful model
they had them uh they had a theory sorry
which gave rise to the standard model
they were able to simulate the standard
model and work out what energy range in
which to find the higgs so then had an
experiment build a collider go to
138.5 gev you have a better memory for
this than i do but there find a peak
get it 11 sigma
higgs job done
um you've got it so what i was going to
say is a to reassure brian or to make
him decide
we're not just going for the origin of
life we're going for the phenomena that
produces life
in general think of it like uh when you
when you look up in the sky let's just
imagine that we
i don't know
it's a few hundred thousand years from
now and humans have emerged slightly
later and they look up in the sky and
all they see is the sun
they don't see any other stars
what they would in they'd be obsessing
about the origin of the sun how did it
come there's fusion where were those
hydrogen atoms those damn hydrogen atoms
how did it happen and then fusion came
but now we look up and say there's a sun
that's cool and they go over there
there's a sun little one's just died
ones have started one died so what i'm
trying to say is of course i'm studying
the origin of life but i'm not just
studying the origin of life i'm under
understanding the emergence of life in
general so i can do statistics and all i
can do in my lab is build the experiment
so now
i like okay i need to build a life a
life generator so what i need to build a
simulator of planet earth have a load of
pots load of warm ponds programming
language pumps and valves doing all the
chemistry for you know but i don't have
a planet or 200 million years i have
some grad students
brilliant grad students 25 of them
and and four years so then i'm
multiplexing it so i've got i've got a
kind of theory which is comp
unreasonable complexity that's my theory
my model is to go and then
generate networks of molecules that will
produce that unreasonable complexity
i then have a threshold which i can talk
about which is i kind of i published a
paper last year alien meter that kind of
works for life
and i now should go run it and i you
know i mean i've done this as time
stamped as 2022 we're getting older all
the time but i will let you know i will
tweet when the experiment is ready to
start
and i'm going to connect my complexity
to twitter and it's just going to talk
right there the chemistry that comes out
so it'll be random and what you need to
do is look at that twitter account and
when when it starts writing or when you
see patterns in the tweets you'll know a
lifeform is emerged in glasgow so yes we
are doing origin of life
um but i want to frame it more broadly
and i also think that um we i would like
to kind of just suggest that you know
the it's a it is quick so the two years
i promised that the ted talk is correct
and as brian knows from doing big
experiments political and all sorts of
things which two years are the most
important
that's right they always say you know
experiment or x discovery is is uh ten
years uh from now and it will always be
so uh but lee let me you know i love you
and i'm gonna keep uh harping on that
fact um so nature's under no obligation
to you know fulfill things on our grant
schedules on our on our you know
biological clocks which is a kosher form
of clock as far as i'm concerned but um
but i want to take you back to 1854
when a fellow scotsman a brilliant lad
just like yourself sir
and he was working away and he
discovered these four laws that are
eponymously named at the maxwell
equations and james clerk was working
away and he discovered that and he said
these imply and impute the laws of
electromagnetic radiation
and how can they propagate through the
seeming void that separates us from the
sun from all these objects that lee's
already described well it must be the
luminiferous ether the vitreous the
virtuous electromagnetic ether
and he said well how does that work and
he went through it and he had this
system of vortices gears pulleys and
ropes and so forth and a microscopic
club which is totally laughable so now
imagine leave twitter existed back then
or how about if twitter existed when
darwin wrote his letter to was it huxley
uh leo correa about the warm little pond
and he said oh it's an if and it's a
very big if and what if you know there
was a twitter you know bot connected to
darwin's warm little pond 1840s 1850s or
what if miller yuri by the way yuri was
stanley uh was was uh
lee uh yuri who was harold yuri rather
who was at uc san diego a mile from my
office here and he at our chemistry
department's named yuri hall and he
worked with his grad student stanley
miller and they came up with this famous
miller yuri experiment which sounds an
awful lot except for the existence of a
of a computing machine next to it 1951
and uh and you could have turned it on
and and maybe connected it to a turing
machine that could then tweet uh and and
that would then you know here we are
here's the here's the you know prototype
of life coming out and it's now it's
doing something complex organized
reducing of entropy collecting
information and providing surprise i
think that's important
and it'd be totally far off from the way
we actually believe and correct me if
i'm wrongly but
i'm gonna be bold because kurt's paying
us you know handsomely to be aggressive
and i'm gonna say i don't think we've
made any progress in this type of field
of miller yuri darwinian warm little
pools since
you know since those original
conjectures i think they've been shown
to be wrong not you know scientific
fraud but there's no evidence that those
chemicals even if they could be
providing sterilized little beakers that
i get at my chemistry stockroom and you
get in your chemistry stockroom with
pipettes that are cleaned and connected
to it to an autoclave
that even so they can reproduce
actual living organisms correct me if
i'm wrong i'm ready for the arrows
no i mean look so i i don't want to so
there's i'm stuck here as a chemist i
mean chemists have made an incredible
achievement since the time of military
right i think the the the the the
problem is
um
the let me yeah so the the experiments
that miliuri did was a bit like um
you doing
the bicep one pro er project
in 1950 and the technology wasn't there
you kind of you we kind of understood
polarization we understand about light
we didn't know anything about the
microwave background so they were they
were kind of they were kind of visionary
and that they had a hint that life
existed oh sure whereas you know the
physicists were like
there's no you know there's no big bang
there's just a steady state model and
all this stuff so they were kind of head
of the physics of that time and so what
they did they were a victim of their own
naivety of simplification
and so and so the the the progress that
was made there is they just said okay
we'll just take some very basic
molecules and put them in a flask and
heat them so the middle your experiment
is literally uh a big bell jar with a a
cycle or circuit we've got a heater and
you have some water methane hydrogen
ammonia okay and these are the elements
you need for most amino acids which will
have carbon hydrogen nitrogen oxygen
some have sulfur in it but let's leave
those out here they didn't put any
sulfur in and so what they showed was
something that i i am i love mathematics
i'm a much better kind of a computer
scientist and mathematician than i am a
kind of historical chemist so for me
when someone says oh here's some glycine
glycine is the simplest amino acid
um conventory it's easy to get it's like
maybe flicking three or four heads in a
row with a coin flip
okay so and and they did this with a lot
of amino acids and so the chemists kind
of they made this and it was still
remarkable because whoa
these simple things can make amino acids
amino acids and proteins is there a link
well of course there's a link in so far
as the atoms in that jar can find their
way into amino acids but we know that
life isn't about amino acids
life is something
different right and so i don't think
they've failed i think the chemists have
been asked to develop a philosophy or
develop a an ontology that just didn't
exist
and i think that that so i you know and
i think the chemists are doing brilliant
things now what's happened in the 50
years well chemists have gone on and
cured disease and made interesting
molecules and we all know that i'm not
here to defend them but the analysis has
got better but leah
aren't you guys still now with things
like the rna world which we have to
discuss i mean isn't it just redux this
this you know redux reaction now what
was the miller uri amino acid now oh no
we know the secret is rna
so i would say
um
within every field so i'm going to try
and do this as delicately as possible um
with every field you have a field that
gets stuck and they are and the origin
of life chemists are really interested
in commentary or chemistry the easiest
route to x y and z and then there and
they see a series of smoking guns and
the thing is i'm sure that brian and i
readily agree that rna is not the answer
to the origin of life but i think i have
an understanding of the underlying
theoretical framework and that's what
i'm going to push brian on in just one
moment so life has little to do with the
actual specific molecules it's a bit
like saying i can only make a motor car
that's you know i don't know let's take
a bmw i discover a bmw or then i
discover a tesla right
the only the you know the the ora let's
say there's the origin of automobiles on
planet out there and it's you know
there's no space for tesla it's just bmw
or there's no space for a bmw it's just
tesla there's only one way of doing it
or kurt's lamborghini or lamborghini
my son is into ferrari
there's not one way of solving that
chemical problem and what i'm here to
reassure brian on he's like whoa
chemistry is special like it's not
the problem that chemists have
is that they um they're they are playing
around in the mess in the middle so here
let me just frame the whole discipline
i'm my my ambition in my lifetime is not
only to get to solve the origin of life
and make artificial life and find aliens
those three things are needed i think
together
um because not one of them is going to
be acceptable i think and also as the
alien discussion is going in our popular
culture right now this is something that
sarah walker has pointed out to me many
times it's really interesting that
people are excited about aliens
and i kind of disagree with brian a
little bit he says if people just get
the find an alien life form they won't
care they will but it needs to be framed
properly because people want to know
they want meaning um so going back to
this origin of life and why is it wrong
well
physicists deal with
low memory systems right that's why we
call them low memory systems physicists
themselves are very high memory
individuals right they have to be good
at mathematics and modeling and so on
low memory systems that means a few
equations can broadly tell show you how
things work
not precisely then you go into chemistry
and chemistry is a bit messier there's
lots more compounds in maine more common
to explosion but again chemist alchemist
whatever we can make new materials
molecules and so on then you get to
biology and that's a medium memory
when you get to biology you have all
this contingency and evolution cambrian
explosion there are legs popping up
everywhere eyes everywhere things calm
down you get to where we we are on earth
with dinosaurs a chance event comes
a dinosaur goes extinct mammals
run around and suddenly we have human
beings uh building iphones and youtube
and and whatever and and i think that
that
me the memory in those increases like
dramatically we can't even conceive
because physics has not
and we say it's all physics fault right
i'm gonna have to i'm not
i'm in defense of the chemist physics
doesn't doesn't understand entropy it's
wrong the definition of entropy is wrong
um sadly this is huge this is really
huge kurt um so lee has a very
provocative unorthodox and not
necessarily accepted within physics
doesn't mean he's wrong but i think we
should put a pin in that and definitely
want to yeah yeah the audience your
audience needs to hear his perspective
and they hopefully will want to hear my
rebuttal too but but lee go i don't want
to interrupt you is this related to
assembly theory or is it different yeah
yeah it's about assembly thinking i'm
unsure how a definition can be wrong
what do you mean by the definition of
entropy is wrong that entropy is trying
to capture something and the definition
doesn't capture let's define entropy for
a second and so it's it's not the
definition isn't wrong it's what we need
to the whole concept is wrong
it's highly it's quite it's like these
are career ending words right there will
be all the the
thermodynamicists out there canceling me
but because thermodynamics are pretty
cool guys and they're like the stats
they're not going to cancel me they
might take pity on me and teach me some
statistical mechanics so what do i mean
so if you uh what is entry all entropy
very loosely is a measure of disorder
so and and and what we say in general i
think it's a process to be
sorry i don't think that's the case uh
do you think that's the case brian that
it's a measure of disorder it is yeah i
know that's colloquially what it is no
no
if you the entrance so if you want to
calculate the entropy of something you
look at the state you look at the actual
state versus the the microstate versus
the number of possible states look at
the fraction of those and and basically
at the when you look at the entropy the
value it tells you how much disorder you
have the lower the number the lower the
disorder the more order the higher the
number the higher the disorder the
higher the number of arrangements that
is the price precise definition of
entropy it goes from the molecular level
or the atomic level all the way up to
the macro level well kurt i should say
that john von neumann said nobody
understands entropy so if you ever
discover something call it entropy
there's like what lee eight different
shannon entropy von neumann oh no but
let's
some clarification is that when people
use the word order we have a certain
meaning in our everyday life in our
vernacular but then when we use the word
entropy it has a specific meaning that
isn't necessarily tied to order though
it's correlated with it and you can see
this with no no no we have to let's go
back because brian will back me up here
the entropy that's used in information
theory is not correct right it is a it
is a colloquialism it is not anchored in
physical reality what is anchored in
physical reality is the basic idea the
idea of a heat engine okay so i want to
talk about the heat engine so basically
what the thermodynamic dynamicists
realized if you want to get maximum
efficiency out of your heat engine you
maximize the temperature difference
between the two parts right and then you
can i know if it's exactly yeah sorry
that's a carnal efficiency right exactly
and so and brian is agreeing because
it's right it's how it works right there
now boltzmann came along and he realized
that he could derive the existence of
molecules of atoms from this approach
it's like abenitio it was amazing right
so you could infer that these molecules
are moving around and they have these
energies associated with them and they
could be added up and they would give
you what you measure right in by
experiment now
that's that's out there what i'm saying
here is human beings create the boundary
conditions of the engine we build the
engine we do work we in we interact on
the on the boundary conditions to make
things happen and then we label the
beginning and the end and the way we
label things we label things in such a
way as an observer that we we kind of
stack the deck so we always see the
entropy change so let's pause there
because that's quite a deep thing we
have to dig down and brian will attack
it in a good way because it needs
clarification now let's go to
information and entropy this is where
things get confusing
shannon
wanted to qualify the amount of noise in
a channel if we're speaking right and he
wanted to think about the number of
possible states how surprising is it if
i get this bit do i get that bit right
and what shannon was able to do is come
up with a very nice mathematical
formalism that look very similar to
entropy okay um on a channel but people
misunderstood and said that everything
is a communication channel but no
shannon says there has to be an encoder
and a decoder and then shannon
information
is can be used
only under those circumstances no
encoder no decode and no shannon
information okay that's what i mean so i
really wanted to take that very
carefully and define those to the best
of my ability and i'm very happy for
brian to correct anything because he's a
better teacher than i am and i think on
this we broadly agree what the
definition is i think just for for kurt
and for the audience who's incredibly
erudite second only to the into the
impossible podcast audience in terms of
judicial brilliance and alacrity of
brain power no i'm just kidding there's
a podcast that brian hosts for those who
are watching called into the impossible
and i recommend you check that out i'll
leave a link in the description
and and kurt is my uh he is my thesis
advisor and all things and youtube has
really helped me tremendously and i have
gratitude for him um so so lee is
eminently correct here i think this is
this is absolutely something that we can
we can orient uh towards and and that
only highlights again this this very
delightful and delicious you have to
understand kurt um me and lee share one
thing in common the curiosity depends on
us being mystified stymied and perhaps
even deceived by nature at certain times
our job is to not deceive ourselves or
other people to get money attention fame
etc but in these contexts when you have
ambiguity again
lee mentioned a lot of topics in that
definition which is eminently correct
insofar as we all agree on things like
temperature
we agree on on basics like
the microstate what constitutes
microstates distributions and
fundamentally if we agree on time and
leigh has some very very again
delightful delicious uh you know
possibly delusional but but wonderful
ideas about time and and its
fundamentality but let's connect let's
keep going back uh to what lee said
which i think is is brilliant and
controversial he said physicists do not
understand entropy which implies
concomitantly with that i think lee
you'll agree that we don't understand
time because time and temperature i
think you could say we might understand
but that's intimately connected to
molecules right you don't have
temperature of a single quark right
that's not substantive to talk about so
chemistry comes in and i think i would
disagree that you know chemists have a
superior understanding i think they have
insight that physicists do not
appreciate and lee is 100 correct we
don't appreciate this molecular story
and i'll just correct one thing that lee
said i don't think boltzmann you know
fundamentally you know prove the
existence of molecules i think that was
einstein later with brownie in motion
which was concomitant with boltzmann and
maxwell's earlier statistical mechanics
but let's just take this back to lee's
controversial statement which is that to
understand time and to understand
entropy we really need to understand
chemistry because they're all
fundamentally
pivoting on a very a very singular hinge
which is a chemical definition or a
practical working definition of entropy
which lee posits comes from chemistry
exclusively correctly
yeah and i think to i mean so the to
going back to boltzmann and the proof of
atoms boltzmann proved i mean you can
add it on
what einstein did that basically the
molecules
are little microstates basically and
that might work so that's a good
correction we must get these corrections
right um so going on with entropy so
what i was saying to you kurt is that
when you you look at a process you say
oh this whole process has occurred
the entropy of the universe has
increased right it's like like some kind
of law and i keep saying to people
what is the basis for that law and this
is really tricky so we get to circular
argument people say well of course if we
do the statistics what we do is we count
everything up
in their in their and put them in you
know how much energy you have how many
of you you know and then we then sum it
up and we look at the entropy we
calculate their number and then we look
at the change so we look at after with
before and after and we look at the
difference there now the problem is with
respect to what are we labeling
and so what i'm saying is that chem
entropy as a term
is useful if you're a god looking down
on your universe and you see the system
and you see the surroundings if you're
doing that you're good i'm not saying
that all everyone using entropy is
insane i'm saying entropy relies on
coarse graining
and coarse graining removes causation
so this is the problem because entropy
basically says everyone says there's no
causation in the universe we don't need
it there's a second law and i'm saying
no
there is no second law
the second law does not need to exist if
you allow causation to exist
and then
and it removes the number of
uncertainties and my universe requires
no second law
no order at the beginning
it only requires causation and the
physical laws we already know so i
remember that it's critical let me let
me just you know because lee is a
delightful ability i wonder if he is
part part a member of the of the tribal
families because uh he talks with his
hands and and and he's just so brilliant
in his uh in his single-mindedness of
discourse but i have to put a pause so
lee is also pushing back on something
that's very controversial and he has
tremendous courage again kurt i know you
wanted to have blood on the floor of the
mat by round five i think we're probably
in round three it's going to get there
we're going to get bloody but one bloody
good thing that that leah said
exclusively courageously i think only on
my podcast interview with him was that
uh chemistry has quote an intelligent
design problem so what and and lee takes
on these intelligent designers which
i've had on my show and and i don't mind
and at least debated them and it's it's
it's kosher in my mind to talk to such
people steven c meyer james two or
others um but fundamentally he has
courage lee has courage in that he is
admitting there is a lack a lacuna in
our understanding of signs which we are
comfortable with because we are making
progress towards an understanding that
hopefully would not involve god but
hopefully if it does involve god chemist
physicists around the world could be
open-minded enough to accept and change
their priors based on that now what he
said
is is fundamentally important two
minutes ago he said he doesn't require a
second law now why is the second law so
problematic for chemists who reject the
intelligent design uh hypothesis which
which obviously lee does and and that is
that because without some low ordered
state which can get into my field of
cosmology how did inflation had the big
bang unfurl if there was no pre-existing
universe a pre-existing collapsing state
perhaps
how do you establish a low entropy state
of the universe for it to grow to
today's facility of information of
complexity of chaos of entropy by 10 to
the 100 orders of magnitude that penrose
has pointed out in the 80s already this
is a huge challenge to cosmology how do
you get to high entropy today if you
didn't start with low entropy in the
beginning people like david albert and
others have postulated something called
the past hypothesis which is basically
by fiat some entity instantiates a zero
entropy or low entropy state i don't i
think that's kind of touching on uh
almost intelligent design like features
but lee's self-consistent if not correct
i'm saying he is self-consistent if he
can avoid the second law's validity
uniformly universally then he precludes
and excludes a need for some designer
and i just wonder lee is that driven by
some desire to eliminate a godhead or is
this fundamentally just an element of a
self-consistent theory of the early
universe that leads to the chemistry
time facility that we just described
um
i mean i'm i was thinking about this
today actually because i was listening
um to something you were saying
and um no i've always really had an
intuition for
time that was different to everyone
else's and i remember my physics teacher
when i was at high school who used to
work at cern
and i was just i was saying this thing
called time and she said you understand
time is nothing it's just the ability to
watch interactive things to happen it is
if you have to distribute energy
you have time and i was just like let's
just
i and for all these years i've just that
just for me has just felt wrong and i
kind of ignored it and
when i came back in and i'm a very
open-minded chemist in the um
for me chemistry is a way of interacting
with the universe to ask questions and
when i look around and i can see that
you have sand on a beach that is an
organic made of silicates there might be
biological stuff in there but you've got
inorganic stuff and then you can see a
blade of grass where there's a molecular
machine in there that's assembling
taking light taking co2 and respiring
you can't help thinking
there must be some incredible force of
nature that we're misunderstanding now i
don't mean like a force of gravity but i
will introduce and this is what assembly
theory quantifies the court that that
physicists should give us a bit of
causation the physicists have taken
causation out of everything in physics
so they have to magically invoke it
which is kind of what's why we have this
free will problem now because we've got
really smart people saying i don't have
free will because i live in a
deterministic universe and then you're
just like well what are we doing this
thing i might as well just run round
naked on the youtube channel because
it's already nobody acts like they have
no free will i mean that's the thing
it's like if you meet somebody who truly
believes that they have no free will and
acts upon it that person's should be
referred to
i think
doesn't sam harris claim but anyway i'm
digressing a bit so what i mean is that
um you have this thing that
that for me the missing force if you
like or the missing phenomena that we
are all missing by removing it by having
entropy
cheat number one
having order at the beginning of the
universe cheat number two and having
emergent time and emergent causation
cheats three and four
is that we're me we're ignoring the fact
that
when you've got a universe just full of
objects let's call them just atoms right
and some energy and you start to break
symmetry
that that symmetry can select
and there's this thing called selection
and you don't need biology for selection
you don't need and don't worry there's
no pan psychism here there is just the
environment can
start to be the shepherd
for the sheep if you like and then the
sheep can become the shepherd and they
switch between the two and you get
complex behavior frozen in now this is
the
point that random events are random but
they are
absolutely monumental in the trajectory
so what i mean if you go to a billiard
table and you just start moving the
balls around
the state that you'll have
number of bounces later will become
precisely controlled by your initial
conditions and some variations
start with different initial conditions
put different energy you'll get to a
different place now imagine
that the system is able to record that
memory of what happened before that
basically physics turns into chemical
chemistry through bond formation and
complex conventory explosion and then
that process is then harnessed when
biology is invented by matter and you
hat you're able to remember what
happened to you at higher higher
dimensionality and that
is what that causation from
quarks to quacks
right we can have a quote on that
from
yeah
that's a much better you're much better
at this than i am right but you you go
from this kind of non-causal system to a
causal system then act on itself so
there's two levels you get to biology
and you get causation trapped in
evolution but then when evolution
produces objects that can act on
themselves we can genetically engineer
ourselves we can play with the climate
we can play with the soil we can play
with technology you get this explosion
of further complexity and that's how it
works and i think that the universe is
literally teeming with um these engines
of causation
and it doesn't need to be we could come
to a drake occasion and go do like earth
you know the fact is there's life
everywhere the sad thing is we probably
won't be able to recognize it other than
if we use assembly theory but that's
obviously my bias right and the prop the
problem i have as a theorist here is i
invented a theory and several
experiments and what my challenge is to
disprove my own theory
with
but and the problem with the discipline
i'm in is the chemist won't even engage
with it to start with and it's taken
them a very long time i have a different
i'm sorry kurt to interrupt go ahead
it's better if i don't say anything okay
it means it's going well
okay although i do have a quick question
yeah
it's for lee and for you brian what's
the definition of order that doesn't
involve entropy
because if you're saying low entropy is
order
well then that sounds like a definition
of order yet the word order was used
prior to the word entropy being invented
so this is really tough so you've asked
for really smart so i'll take a stab at
it and brian will as well you can define
information in terms of your certainty
about what's going to happen next i take
a coin right and i say i'm going to flip
my coin and i have no idea i have no pri
i have no nothing to suggest that it's a
weighted coin i will assign a prior that
i'm going to give you know 50 head or
sales and i'll collect data and i'll
update
when you're that so that update
constitutes some information when you're
and that is the same type of thing you
want to have a look at an order order is
a really odd thing because order is
about registry and so i would say that
order
happens
when you have no constraints let's say
oh and you allow things to cool down so
let's just take a phase transition you
take some water vapor and you know that
water vapor to kind of precipitate and
grow a
an ice crystal
okay and if you allow that to happen
very slowly
the the order
will arise from the fact that molecules
in that ice crystal the water molecules
will take the correct low energy
configuration to make a nice tetrahedral
symmetry and then you'll get no defects
in there and you'll produce this perfect
object that just happens because the
laws of physics give you that so order
arises when you have no the constraints
are minimal
that's kind of a really nice definition
of order
um and it's hard because lots of people
argue and they bring in it's all
anthropologic you know
my kids bedroom is not ordered you will
claim it is right but you know so that's
and then you then frame in these
entropic and information arguments but
you say hey what is information
information is about uncertainty what is
entropy entropy is about disorder so one
way of looking at is
causation or information for me is
almost the inverse of entropy so when i
burn something
i know how much entropy has changed so
if i burn a book
i in principle or i take a book to the
event horizon and black hole right
you're going to get all the information
back out talking radiation i won't be i
count it but i should be able to work
out what it's roughly going to be so i
it tells you what i've lost it's never
told me what i have and that's why i'm
pushing so hard on this is entropy is
almost like the inverse it tells me that
i lost stuff it can never tell me what i
had
yeah i very much agree with that i would
only add on just another example think
of a pendulum clock a grandfather clock
with a pendulum swinging back and forth
in vacuum
you can use that to tell time
and actually i think it's the minimal
clock lee works a lot on minimal systems
and and systems that exhibit uh you know
features of of the very most simple
basics in essence of the phenomena not
simple in terms of like dumb but but
simple in terms of elementary and
important um so you can have this clock
swinging back and forth and you can use
it to tell time i.e this you know
describe order but if and only if you
you define the direction of the arrow of
time right because a pendulum is timed
translation symmetric if i didn't tell
you where it started i swung the plumb
bomb out over here and let it go you
wouldn't know uh the absolute origin of
time but uh but you could still count
time in a parametric relative way you
could say so many cycles of the pendulum
later and you could say that's in the
forward but
if the universe were you know arranged
differently the laws of physics work for
newtonian physics in the absence of heat
and so forth work uh the other way so
yes so at least right you imply some
constraint and then you can do stuff
without imposing uh this interplay
between entropy time and order but only
if you supply at least the minimum bit
of information i.e what was the initial
condition but to get back to lee's
point i think this will go back to our
rubric that we established in the ground
rules you know when lee and i were to
nose at the beginning and kurt was like
pushing us and we were like
you know at the very beginning of the
fight um
you know we we should have some
explanation of of what our priors are
and how we could change our our minds uh
so one thing that leah said just now and
said to me on my podcast anne has said
uh in in many of his wonderful debates
and again i give him credit for his
courage this is so rare that you have a
publix-facing um scientist at the
highest level regius professor at the uk
which is like appointed by the queen so
i think he has to like taste test all
her food to make sure she doesn't die
like martin reese he tells the queen her
horoscope as the royal astronomer lee is
like that level in in in in his
profession so let me say that again
prefacing with respect um lee has
basically claimed that life is abundant
and so to me in the universe and and
he's gone so far as to make a life
detection machine which after his
twitter bot you know in the warm
darwinian pool registers you know um you
know i'm setting up my twitter like jack
did you know 20 years ago
after that he's going to also you know
provide the signal coming in from the
universe autonomously generated based on
fundamental mathematical principles
connected to computational devices
turing machines
but that is predicated on this bias i
call you out i use the b word lee
you are biased that there is a life is
plentiful throughout the universe and i
have to say
you know with the drake equation which
we can write down and i give it to my
undergraduate students and and lee knows
it backwards and forwards the most
important thing in any equation lee
correct me if i'm wrong is not that you
get the answer it's how you account for
your uncertainties your statistical
uncertainties which are easy to
calculate
and your systematic uncertainties which
are very very difficult i use this
example in a talk i gave in the belly of
the beast guys i went to the seti
institute which we can talk about later
i gave a talk and said what if you apply
the drake equation to the san diego zoo
where i am
and he said how many people are in the
san diego zoo right now and i go through
the calculation i come out with a number
and it's like 8 000.
and that's great except when i do the
error bars if i account for each one of
the terms that goes into the drake
equation for the san diego zoo and feel
free to estimate example of a fermi type
problem if you don't include the error
bars it's meaningless it's worthless so
i believe that league should say that
there's 100 you know that life is
abundant but i would i want to know his
error bars and i want to know how can he
go about reducing those error bars in
other words disproving himself rather
than confirming that life is abundant
necessarily what are the potential
pitfalls traps biases confirmation
otherwise that this abundance detector
that you have uh that you have developed
and promoted um has any degree of
credulity right now that there's a
hundred percent as you said there's a
hundred percent chance i'm closer to
zero percent chance of life in the
universe again no one would like to
believe it more than me especially
intelligent aliens that could teach us
the laws of physics at the 25th century
right now so i can win that nobel prize
finally but but i want to know i'm with
you
so let me let me unpack this let me
qualify because i think i mean we're
violently agreeing so um my intuition
the way i understand how chemistry works
is i think there's life everywhere i
didn't quite say a hundred percent brian
is kind of i have you on record saying a
hundred percent i know that's fine
that's fine i'm happy to stand by i
think it's great it's like you're
you're really putting me there and you
know going me in the corner and just
throwing the punches and i would say
that um
it it is i'm i i i wouldn't say i'm
biased i'm optimistic
but if you were to say league how much
evidence do you have for life elsewhere
in the universe other than zero i have
zero evidence
but i would you know i could kind of say
it brian you know
how hey brian let's let's set fire to
something right like i don't know some
carbon how much evidence do you have for
carbon being on fire in oxygen in the
universe you might
probably wouldn't
probably wouldn't have any right but he
knows what happens on earth and knows
how simple it is and and you could
probably go yeah i could probably
imagine some carbon being on fire
somewhere
kelvin used to think the sun was powered
with coal right but when he did the math
he just worked out and have an energy so
totally i have no evidence there's life
elsewhere in the universe zero there's
some hints there might have been life on
mars there's some hints that there might
be some interesting stuff on venus we're
excited about going to europa and
enceladus right so i had just to be
clear for everyone listening zero i have
zero evidence does that mean that i'm
somehow life religious no no no no what
i'm saying is chemistry is so easy
so quick
and we there are so many missing gaps
what is the likelihood here is the
likelihood that life is just vanishing
hard or is it that we don't actually
know what how how we store information
in chemical systems when an evolution
works because i i do agree
that um
there's probably life in the universe
because life is we're using life as a
very i'm using life as a very broad
catch-all term for the following and i'm
saying that when there is selection
there will eventually be some kind of
evolution and that evolution will
normally
get give rise at some point in time to a
luca and that luca will go on and brian
is absolutely right there's lots of
fragile links in there and we just don't
know the point about the drake equation
however is this the drake equation is
not a law it's not really an equation
it's a kind of made-up thing
but i do think that brian and i should
sit down and say okay
how many stars how many planets
what fraction of the planets are even
you know my motto here is let's allow
any planet where bonds are allowed
covalent bonds because covalent bonds
that let's just let's allow life on all
let's allow all those to be lifeline so
then you know why i say where there's
bond there's hope
so
that's important because as kurt always
points out you know you want to have
these no-go theorems right kurt this is
something that's a fixture on your
channel you've been paying attention
brian yeah and i'm stipulating to you
lee i'm willing to change my mind that
there is no no-go theorem um you know so
in other words the probability is
greater than zero and i should never say
zero and i didn't say zero i said i
think it's closer to zero but uh but i
agree with you bonds the proclivity of
bonds and the vicinity of carbon to make
bonds and so forth um i would say
there's lots of evidence of chemical
reaction i mean we have examples of
amino acids at high redshift you know
that we can detect uh and quasar
absorption features and we know
chemistry takes place in in distant
objects but but you know uh this main
point is well taken yeah and as i and i
continue to push back and say you know
i mean
my my my conviction is my my kind of my
humbleness really because
the earth isn't that special it's a rock
the solar system we've got some carbon
we've got some oxygen yeah people say oh
it's lucky that we had a clean up that
jupiter could clean up everything for us
and all this ah i don't know we don't
know what time life emerged on earth in
100 million years it might be lucky for
us that we have intelligent life and i'm
very happy to say to you know i say to
ufo believers all the time
the chances that an intelligent lifeform
has sent ufo to earth is like i mean
it's not zero but there are other
explanations right i mean this is other
things we can do i mean i know eric
weinstein at the moment has gone a bit
kind of ufo you know let's think about
it but i think he's doing it for not not
to be disrupt well to be disruptive not
disingenuous and to get people to take
people's temperature but coming back to
this i would say i have seen no no-go
theorems for for know why life shouldn't
exist elsewhere and given that i'm an
internal optimist will say well look
there should be it should be everywhere
but what i'm super excited about is i
have a i'm willing to make a wager brian
is still young i'm even younger
um not that much but uh um but in the
next decade or two we'll get a go to
enceladus in europa
and and titan and i'm willing to bet
that if there if we do find any evidence
of life on these
um objects they will be totally
different to life on earth because
they've had a completely different
history there is no relationship whereas
we might find life on mars if we haven't
put life on mars by mistake we might
find evidence of primitive life on mars
like going to earth and seeded earth
right yeah i i agree with that i mean
but that pushes things back that's just
changing the day but let me yeah yeah
exactly i mean life on earth and life
are likely to be coupled that's not
that's nothing if we go to mars we find
earth like life
i'll be happy for a day and i'll watch
the nobel prizes be given but i'm like
that hasn't told me anything new as a
scientist i want to discover something
new if i went to enceladus if i found
life form based on something that isn't
rna
that would be it for me that would just
be like the most amazing event in the
universe why well if i could find
different life enceladus i could start
to frame the likelihood of alien life in
our local group okay
i could think about how we could look at
making new technologies based on living
systems on earth and really even more
important in fact i almost have the same
passion that brian has for understand
the origin of the universe um
for this is that if we can make life on
earth and understand the origin of life
we might be able to start to accept that
life on earth that we have right now in
our ecosystem
is very precious
and how is a thing and we need to think
about framing
this
living artifact this little cultural
you know jewel that we need to keep to
be as persistent for as long as possible
and to create maximum flourishing for
our little moral kind of
work part in the universe so i think
almost way if you know there are two
films i watched i know i'm talking a lot
but there's two what films that came out
the same year one called ad astra which
was the most depressing the brian
keating movie you know
you're just as good looking as brad pitt
you know
so and then you know and there is
another film called cosmos which was a
low budget uk movie which i like and you
can watch them because one basically
both about should we find life and one
finds life very optimistic comes to
earth and says we're here and the other
one is like miserable there's no life
anywhere and for me
i i think the difference between us is
i'm an optimist because i understand my
chemistry
and i'm a chemist you're an optimist in
your field you understand that and i'm
trying to i'm trying to borrow a bit of
your
intuition and i'm trying to lend you a
bit of mind and see if we can change
each other's mind from that point of
view but you're absolutely right i have
no evidence but i have no reason why it
can't happen there is nothing magic
about life on earth
yeah well i wonder if we could have a
no-go theorem if you uh if you would
agree and then you know perhaps that
would make our our generous host
generous good looking and uh and
uh just with a delightful aroma although
i've never met him in person kurt's one
of my best friends that i've never met
in person i hope to rectify that in the
very near future you too lee um but you
brought up eric you brought up and so i
find that there is sort of a uh a wish
fulfillment aspect in in in many of
these things including in this huge and
deservedly so excitement over jwst i
mean i basically heard people portraying
one of the science cases for jwst
tantamount to well we're going to see
like cities on exoplanet you know like
no you're not you're going to see like
spectral lines and and often eric has
talked about data and collecting data um
and and it's our data the hubble space
telescopes are like
well it's data but like take the hubble
deep field i love mentioning this topic
so the hubble deep field is data but
actually we don't use it uh the data the
image for anything it's a screen saver i
call it the cosmic screen saver cosmic
wallpaper and that's all the image
itself is the data is within it so if
there's a ufo floating around in there
that is not the same as what astronomers
call the type of evidence that we
associate with data stuff that we can be
quantitative and analyze spectral time
domain uh
multi-waterfall display you know we can
do a ton of stuff with actual with the
photon information not just the image
information the picture information
um now mentioning this there there
there are you know concerns about what
the implication would be and so i'm
curious to to know why if life is so
abundant
and then you sprinkle in some darwinian
evolution why isn't you know a
technological life abundant and why
isn't it more plausible than not it
seems like you're saying you're you're
kind of a
a life maximalist but a ufo minimalist
so so tell me what how can you rectify
those two things because it would seem
to me unless there's a no-go theorem
against it that maybe there is more hope
i get around that by saying i don't
think life exists elsewhere besides the
earth and if it does it's from the earth
via panspermic processes but but tell me
what what could potentially uh forbid
life from evolving technologically
yeah yeah so uh so i'm gonna say a
couple of things so i think kurt if you
want to go to assembly through we'll do
that in a minute i think it's quite
important this story well let me answer
brian's question i actually so i think
you know there's a scooby-doo you know
the ways the the villain says you pissed
pesky kids i'm gonna say the reason why
we can't see technological life is you
pesky physicists because the universe is
really big and things are accelerating
away and it's you know and sadly
um you know i'd love to break the i'd
love to understand more about the the
way the universe is and the speed of
light and get around but the fact is
there seems to be little indication that
we can have wormholes and and break the
speed of light and and you know
designing
as a quick clarification i'm sorry to
interject lee then when you say that
life is abundant in the universe are you
not referring to the observable universe
sure i think it's abundant in the
observable universe and we'll learn how
to find it and i think actually
frustratingly we probably will find
techno signatures uh uh you know hints
of them and not just hints hints that
brian and i will look at the data we'll
look at the uncertainty the error bars
your point is taken i haven't forgotten
it's a very good point brian and we will
then go well the balance is fact here is
like we will be it is possible remotely
to get data
uh um squeeze down those areas and know
for sure there's alien technological
life elsewhere in the universe we could
do it okay and don't let nasa and other
people say it's not we can do it we can
detect the higgs boson if we can look at
the cosmic microwave background we will
be our fine technological um signatures
but we but we need a better theory which
i'm trying to introduce it might not be
the right one but i've got a feeling
it's going in that direction but to
answer the question where all the
technology is there's a number of
answers to that but i want to say
something quite profound
if time really is a thing and let's say
time is a commodity
and at the beginning of our local
universe where the laws are now i'm
going to define time and this is going
to be like
i mean i'm not a very good singer but
this is going to be like brian hearing a
really bad singer
and he's like breaking physics
but here i'll try
at the origin of the universe there was
some kind of singularity which basically
we seem to be we all kind of one
quantumly connected one particle let's
say and through that causal
aperture
the
the the the size of the electron the
what you know the the the charge to mass
ratio of the electron the gravitational
for all the forces would produce or all
that was produced there right in that
single point because people say the laws
and all the constants the constants are
just consistencies right and so so we
have that
and then from that that process that
point in time where the universe
expanded
and i think
again brian has the history of the
universe down like i think if i remember
i'm studying you that all the hydrogen
in the universe was made in the first 20
minutes or something which is just a
mind-blowing uh kind of fact and it's
true than the big bang theory tv show
exactly that's great so now you've got
this stuff right
in time
now the reason is the clock is ticking
now at that time you don't have enough
states in the universe
to actually produce life it's kind of
cool
basically you actually they're the fermi
paradox and i'm saying i have to qualify
this because i'm stealing this idea i
agree with it from sarah walker so i you
know i'm not very good well i should be
clear i should steal more ideas but but
she's convinced me and i and i also
think it's true it's a natural
consequence of assembly theory the fermi
paradox is not about the fact that we
that we don't see the aliens just
the we're looking back in time and at
that time the universe didn't have the
ability to produce technology so it's
like a fermi filter and think for a
second it's like oh [ __ ]
we looking back in time the universe
didn't have the ability to produce
technology at that time
we have to look in a different way
actually i i'll push back again uh just
to say that there was an epoch in the
universe where you didn't need a hard
rocky planet to sustain uh room
temperature liquid water and that was a
time about you know eight billion years
ago when the universe curt was at the
temperature above zero degrees celsius
which is uh you know about 50 degrees
warmer than it is in toronto or glasgow
i'm just trying to make you guys jealous
you'll visit me here in san diego in
january sometime um so the universe
could have liquid water for millions
billions of years until it become frozen
water um and so actually no there
there's a reverse filter there there's
sort of a city no no no no that's that i
have to push back that's quite nice but
i'm saying
something very
profound in terms of the the number of
states available i don't care how much
water's available who cares what i care
about is a combinatorial state space
remember i'm not a chemist here i'm a
mathematician but in the states so
you're right with kurt but kurt the
amount i'm going to have sarah on my
show next week but but uh and i'll ask
her about this but the the i mean is it
galaxy is one galaxy sufficient uh sp
estate space to create technological
life obviously this is what we're this
is what i think i think the answer is no
right and i what we just let's just keep
going with this argument there's let's
just make a conjecture i don't know
right but isn't it interesting you've
got a smaller volume in the universe
time is a thing so you're not going back
and forth so you have to
um there's this causal chain of events i
don't know how delicate it plays into
your argument really nicely what
sequence of events have to happen in the
first 20 minutes the next 200 million
years the next two billion years to
prepare the universe to be able to
metabolize elements fusion right
produce objects that can then have
enough structure enough surface area for
selection to occur over a period of time
so you might not you might need
stability of a few hundred million years
with a certain gravitational force but
let's not add that on i'm just saying
hey wouldn't it be cool if the fermi
paradox is actually just evidence the
universe had not yet had enough causal
history to produce life
we popped up as soon as it could so we
should go ah okay let's now i'll say
let's just make this very simple for
ourselves and say life in the universe
kind of started to emerge when life
let's say there's nothing special about
earth
happened quickly
so life was possible in the universe
about four billion years ago and so what
we now do is we reframe our observations
and we look around i'm just making this
up so new idea i had today thanks to
sarah's idea and brian's question and
yours did you come up with the
metabolized elements because that's a
cool line i'm gonna steal that yeah yeah
i just made it up i wouldn't steal it
from sarah i would steal it from you no
no no i you could steal that from me i
just made it up just now um and so
you've kind of got this idea that
basically
um you're creating this infrastructure
for causation
that that allows you to go a bit further
and and so what happens i don't know i
mean if only we had an astronomer who
understood how to look back here like if
you read through the lines right we're
going to now restrict ourselves looking
for a four billion year old light cone
and we look at the exoplanets other
objects how does that reframe
the search for life or intelligence so i
mean there's lots of ideas there so the
conjecture is
there is a filter that is just the
universe wasn't capable of producing
life until a particular time now it is
then technology and then how does that
go on and that plays into redoing our
error bars in the in the in the in the
fermi paradox and in the drake equation
and also i hide my only shield brian is
i don't see anything magic on earth
so it's probably possible elsewhere
because okay so that's a great point let
me interject because you're
it's difficult to interject without
interrupting i'm sorry lee no no it's
all good your podcast uh you you beat us
in come on yeah okay great you use many
ands and so i'm not sure if the sentence
is complete or if it's run-on and i
don't want to seem rude okay so brian
you just made a great point what is an
example of some other phenomenon that
happens on earth that doesn't occur
elsewhere in the universe so water waves
maybe one well there's maybe water waves
and mountains atmosphere okay so
given that it sounds like there's
nothing special about earth's life so
why are you isolating earth's life
as saying well that's unique
on example
if these plot you know it's like they
want to have their you know primordial
soup and eat it too you know they want
to say it's ubiquitous these processes
are generic uh and yet not seeing it you
know it's more than just a fermi paradox
and i will push back on sarah gently
with respect because i love her work uh
but but the fact is you know those are
almost borderline you know kind of ideas
that i hear from intelligent designers
too you know which is that the laws of
physics the state space of the laws of
physics the constants of nature the mass
of the electron the uh fine structure
constant all the things you talked about
are implied um those you know are can be
con conflated with you know some kind of
low entropy state instantiated by a
designer i don't want to talk about that
except to say that i don't think that
that pushes the pro that filter is very
fine cor fine grain and i will talk to
her about it but i do want to say that
again generically speaking these
processes are ubiquitous so therefore
the non-observation like that should go
into the fermi paradox not that the
universe is large uh that these
processes are uh you know we we just
detected uh you know we've detected uh
helioseismological effects on other
stars we've detected uh the existence of
you know what we think are continental
you know patterns so tectonic you know
potential potentiality for uh tectonic
activity which we do believe some
believe are but all this kind of pushes
things back like one of my big um gripes
against the seti institute which i know
and love and i've had jill tarter and
seth sostak and i've donated to them um
and and i've spoken there but you know i
started to get a little bit suspicious
when a couple years ago they started
shifting away from the
existence of live techno signatures to
extremophiles here on earth i don't
think that necessarily answers or gets
to the heart of the question certainly
not of extraterrestrial intelligence to
know some smoky uh deep smoker has uh
has bacteria or cyanogenic bacteria or
or prokaryotic type whatever that's
interesting but it's not aligned with
eti that's what i care about i mean
yeah let's cut the bs what we really
care about is making contact as eric
says you know if you could short circuit
and get to the laws of the 25th century
and get to the other side maybe we would
pass the great filter you know as it's
been called and protect ourselves and i
i happen to think that might be wishful
thinking but i commend eric for working
on a theory to perhaps unlock some of
these uh some of these portals as he
calls it um but but nevertheless i i
think again
is there you know is there a rubric that
you and i could agree on or or disagree
on and i think the audience would like
to know
are there um in other words if you hear
you know there's been an a credible
account louis elizondo pass guest on
kurt show um you know has claimed you
know really very very
high credence levels in the existence of
extraterrestrials capable of
technologically navigating across our
galaxy correct me if i'm misstating or
overstating the basic point as a
physicist cares about um and that is um
you know non god bless you lee non god
bless you or whatever
darwin bless you darwin bless you when
you sneeze i have to say that uh but but
he's making this so can we by laws of
chemistry physics assembly whatever can
we say no we actually shouldn't have the
cr you know credulity that lee that uh
that luis has uh and instead we should
he should update his priors based on
these following chemical physical
mathematical laws is there a way that we
can do that for this i think so i think
there's a way to do this let me just
answer a little bit and then i'll
explain assembly theory so yeah i think
what i think is likely to happen
if
i mean i don't know i mean like i have
no
i'm a curious i would i think it's
likely that we if life exists in the
solar system
some chemical lice life
um i'm i'm optimistic that we'll go and
find some evidence with some
you know sending dragonfly to titan the
mass spectrometer on it we're going to
hopefully go to europa and so on
we're going to hopefully do origin of
life on earth and when i succeed but
don't get the nobel prize i can write my
other book you know i can get brian to
do it forward in it and all that because
we chemists hate it and what we're
likely to do i think is we should be
looking for technology technological
techno signatures
you know i mean i think that the
exoplanet we're going to detect an
exoplanet of oxygen on them so we found
life and that's just going to be baloney
so that's that i agree with brian so let
me just tell you briefly what assembly
theory is because assembly theory is
actually a kind of a cool way of
actually
doing entropy without labeling and it's
just about as a chemist i realized years
ago
that there are molecules on earth that
are just weird right weird molecules
like really complex and so let's just
take a molecule that i that is used a
lot called taxol taxol
is made by the pacific yew tree it's a
metabolism it's a it's a it's a
secondary metabolite which means it's
made by protein interaction proteins in
the cell and that molecule is really
special because it's very good at um
killing
vascularization of cancer tumors so
people get that and they they they use
it as an anti-cancer drug now to make
this molecule it's like got 62 carbon
atoms you know load of oxygen atoms
nitrogen and so on in this pattern
and this molecule has a molecular weight
of about
852.66
something like this someone would go and
check it now it's wrong
it's like okay like i'll google it
whilst i'm saying but it's a big
molecular weight and it's a fingerprint
and the way that molecule works is the
way the commentary chemistry works that
molecule
is
beautiful it's like a rembrandt right
it's in its features
but chemists can make loads of it so you
can make literally
um 10 to the 23
6.022 times 10 to the 23 and that's one
mole so you have one mole of taxol so
that's 10 to the 23 identical copies and
that's made in biology on earth human
beings can make it in the lab but
if brian and i did the math together and
we said right we'll look at that
molecule we'll work out what is the
probability
that that molecule
could form randomly in a plasma in the
universe
it's basically one in a like
countless in 10 or 100 right maybe more
that's just for one molecule so if you
find a detectable amount you're like oh
oh my god this is like the biggest
coincidence ever so that's where
assembly theory was born
and i realized that there's lots of
molecules on earth that pass the great
filter they are made by biology and i
realize they can make a detection system
that detects molecules that are above
that threshold of complexity and that
when you do random miliuri and random
stuff
get meteorites and look at the organic
chemistry they are way below that filter
they have an assembly number and what
assembly theory does is it says like
take your molecule put it on a graph
what is the shortest route you can get
from your atoms to that target the
shortest possible route how many steps
right so it's a bit like you take the
word abracadabra if you were to make if
you've got a b
uh um you know c r a how many steps
would you need to make the word
abracadabra well you can do it in in a
much number the number of letters in the
in the word because you can reuse some
parts and so my conjecture is assembly
theory says he finds where there's
memory of contingency in a chain so it
looks for lossless compressibility
that's kind of cool right it's a bit
like a information theory compression
shannon
but it's just like that what is the
shortest route to get there because
like brian
i'm as an experimentalist the data is
more important than my feelings that's
right and so you know it's like
so i'm like
you just sounded like ben shapiro for a
second
yeah i love ben shapiro
and so
it's really important that we understand
that because
it work it's pervasive right where
people just think that and chemists
think that complex molecules this is
where the chemists
they're getting they're beginning to
change their view
and what i'm trying to say is that the
the chemists don't because they take it
for granted that there's complex
chemistry everyone's saying hey guys
it's not just rna that's important atp
is important you know that's my that's
my joke lee i say you know in in
economics you know past performance is
no guarantee of future results it's like
we have past performance evidence here
on earth but
that's no guarantee so assembly theory
what it does it allows you given a
complex molecule you can work out the
likelihood it formed by chance
and and that i think is fairly
irrefutable although publishing that
paper last year took me six goes right i
sent it to them why do you think that is
well because they are well it took me my
sense of nature i almost got in right
senate nature i got three reports back
two said wow one said
can't be right
so i wrote back and and so then later
what do we do and i said well
we can ask the referee why it can't be
right so he said i'll do that then and
they're everywhere who said the referee
why can't it be right and the referee
said in the second round
because it's impossible
we're like okay this is like i kid you
not right this is a conversation we had
with the editor i said but here's the
data are you saying we fabricated the
data
and the referee just said it's
impossible
and we went in this loop and what
actually happened is one of the referees
fabricated
a data from a paper to assert that we
couldn't be right that's how desperate
they were i got the evidence right come
back
they said in this paper it says that
complexity is important is already
present in outer space blah blah blah
blah
and
and the editor read it went off reject
again and when i pointed to the editor
that the referee took the word complex
mixtures have been found in space and
changed it to complex molecules because
they were so believing the complex
molecules are a free lunch
um
i then went to the fifth round to review
and the editor by this point was like
just like
go away we're not publishing i said no
we're gonna i believe in the rule of
peer review i'm answering all your
points
this is important it's important we
change people's views of complexity
because brian is on a really good side
where you're saying hey i want the data
i know that nothing is for free and the
chemist in the middle saying everything
is for free complexity happens and i'm
in the middle saying no i can count it
and quantify and here it is what
actually happened it was rejected
right because of for i won't go into i
don't want to complain i'm a very lucky
um scientist i love doing the science i
just feel bad for the research group but
i got it published i published in nature
communications and that paper was
downloaded 27 000 times in five months
um because we presented the theory the
mass spec and all the evidence we had a
little meteorites we even got scottish
whiskey and we proved that scottish
whiskey is evidence of life because
there's complexity in the peak right
we're sure it works so we know we can
fingerprint life on earth and molecules
um and so it's but we realized something
more that assembly theory is about just
something about molecules it's about
every time you have a step on your path
and that you make a decision let's say
you go down a street you say i'm going
to go left today you go left and say
right i'm going to go left again then
i'm going to go right then go left and
right and you find yourself in a very
particular spot
that contingency is print on your
history right there's a lot of
mathematics on that
and we're finding that this is the
the assembly theory that we generate and
i haven't spoken to brian about it
because sarah and i just finishing the
paper and oh my god it works and what i
mean by that i mean that i can take a
kilogram of sand and calculate the
assembly of that kilogram of sand and i
can calculate take a kilogram of e coli
and calculate the assembly assembly is a
number like entropy
an entropy tells you the causal power of
the object and of course the causal
power of a kilogram of a kilo of e coli
is vastly higher than the kilogram of
sand because the sound can do nothing so
what about the uh assembly of rule 38
wolfram's you know raw well and
you'll hear about this in a few weeks
maybe but the problem with that is that
is again a labeled system so rule 38
doesn't exist outside of a von neumann
machine and graph paper an observer
putting the rules in so yeah so there's
so the problem is and physicists get
stuck with things that give complexity
that aren't really complexity it's just
games with numbers
and and i think that i've got a little
bit of work to do with that and i think
the wolfram's ideas here are pretty cool
i think they're not they're not the
problem is with wolfram he traps himself
in a line of thought and doesn't talk to
anyone and think he's the lost genius a
bit like eric actually and no one will
talk to him we'll talk to him in fact
he's got a lot of good ideas that might
actually be right but
not only have i talked to him and i've
talked to eric i've talked to him and
eric at the same time i'm like oh cool
i'd love to take part in that
conversation because i maybe could bang
their heads together
assembly theory tells you about
causation it's now measurable
and that's why i'm excited because we're
going to start to roll this out
in in inanimate objects and it will help
physics i think newton screwed physics
because screw
n newton and there's a hell of a thing
to say i'm british right i love newton
you know there's a lot of coins and on
our notes and everything but leibniz
understood assembly theory and i've been
reading philosophy for the last few
weeks if you read the monadology from
leibniz you'll see that he understood
assembly theory and that objects have
souls
this cup has a soul and you're like you
can use legal arnold pants i can say no
no the soul is not in the cup but it's
in the causal structure of the person
that made it who made it who made it who
made it this cup is a fantastically
improbable object that cannot have
existed at a long line of cup makers
that's where the soul of the cup is okay
let's let brian respond to what you've
said
well you know i think i mean it's
unassailable to say that you know
complexity begets complexity and again
that lee will take on intelligent
designers with one fist but he'll also
you know take on chemists uh with the
other and say look we we have to address
you know as uh
as uh you know roger penrose calls the
mastodon in the room which is you know
this surprising you know uh feature
about the universe that we can
comprehend it we tend to impose you know
consciousness upon it and our
definitions our contingent upon our
causal history and how we were assembled
you know and i think the ultimate theory
of everything when it comes to what
lee's working on will have to involve
the observer which will undoubtedly then
finally force him to get into
fundamentals of quantum mechanics which
i don't think he can call chemistry i'm
okay with you calling you know entropy
and thermodynamics chemistry but i think
you know the uh elementary foundations
of quantum mechanics that's a stretch
i've always wanted to be a physicist
that's okay okay yeah well me too but
you know i i lapsed and became an
astrophysicist
but i think um
you know when we talk about how uh you
know this this can be used to to kind of
um
as i say be quantitative how we can get
something out of it deliver some value
to the audience uh certainly these are
and the last the more flexible we are i
think the more can be understood but
maybe maybe to even narrow down and come
back to the original definition of
things i think to have a taxonomy you
know what what is it that the the name
is not the thing uh there's there's some
principle like that right um and so so
yes describing things that are complex
and are have originators in a mind that
on the one hand is beautiful it's
elegant it's it's simple and again in in
a praiseworthy fashion not in a
childless fashion on the other hand i do
think we have to then confront the
ultimate you know question of you know
is there does there have to be some mind
at work behind the cup behind the 747
behind the uh the the dna code and i i i
think we know we've agreed not to really
get into this this notion but i think it
at some level we just get to this a
eventual chicken or egg and this monta
bailey you know retreat and i guess you
know
i think i think the ultimate you know uh
the ultimate benefit of this approach is
is that it it gives a plausible scenario
for life to arise from inanimate objects
that's that's an ultimate it's a way to
quantify when something is animate let's
just say or was created by something
adamant um
and i think you know to look at how
we can do better and and maybe go
further into which i think is really
important uh you know is life abundant
and technological i think kurt's
audience appreciates that and i think
you know we haven't spoken so much about
that maybe we can talk about that um you
know how and what could we glean from
the search as a search you know and
where are we going qualvadas you know
where are we going with with the search
is it important is a good use of of
chemist's time of physicist time uh et
cetera to look at these uh reported
unexplained phenomena um can that tell
us something is this something that
interests you and and me and and maybe
you know kurt can can lead us in that
path and and kind of yeah really i mean
we're at a very interesting you know
point in time and a lot of it has to do
with people that kurt's had on the show
and that i've tried to have on my
podcast as well um and i think that you
know kind of the abiogenesis
argument is is you know you've
eloquently described it um i think you
know if we look maybe as kurt as an
impartial observer maybe we could say
like where are you kurt in this
discussion because i think you're a
proxy for your
audience how do we how how are you
feeling about the prospects of the
ultimate question
life from non-life and then we could
talk about universe from non-universe we
can talk about consciousness from
inanimate matter and we can talk about
technological matter from conscious
matter but um where are you sitting
right now kurt
if we use
lee's definition of life which is
what begets some high assembly number
then it sounds like
it's almost like pan psychos and pan
lifeism because it's a circular
definition of life where okay well what
would produce that well then we'd get
down to the atoms which produce and so
on and so on so it sounds like life is
abundant if we use the definition that
life is what produces life
let me qualify one second no so what i'm
saying is you have random events
that basically um
increasing causal power and there's a
phase transition to life right life
doesn't just appear magically right
we've already there is but there's a
causation in the universe right the
universe does do some stuff before life
there's a phase transition because then
evolution can do stuff
like that which is just you can and what
it what can and we could there is a
meaning to this which we can come to
it's not pan psychism i totally refute
well no let's be friendly to the pan
psychists because there are interesting
things there but i think there's a
mischaracterization
the pan psychists want something there
but i would argue they want causation
and they want and they're missing out on
causations there's causations there and
then there's biology and then there's
technology so i'm i'm i don't think it's
circular but i think you're really right
to push on it because i think your your
listeners your viewers will be like well
come on it what do i mean i mean rocks
can
through their random interactions can
have memories and those memories just
randomly will be
um trapped in a causal chain which will
allow certain other processes to occur
it's not magic it's contingent
tell me if i'm understanding it
correctly it sounds like in your model
life is not binary it's not alive or
dead it's actually a continuous spectrum
and if that's the case then what i'm
saying that there is no zero to life
there's no zero i think life is a kind
of island right this is why we have so
difficult pinning it down the physics
it's like is this is my cup alive no was
my cup produced by life yes am i alive
yes i think so um you know
so there's kind of this is a movable
feast in a way in the same way
consciousness
is kind of we have more so agency we
have maximum agency in our bodies right
now but newton is still exerting agency
over all of us
because of what he did that life form
and it's kind of cool so yes you're
absolutely right i think life is kind of
a continuum and there's a phase
transition to you have there is really a
lot of causal power and you get
something special with that that faith
transition is an intuition at this point
is it formalized
we're formalizing it yeah and doing
experiments and i think that exactly it
there's a nobel prize there the nobel
prize there's another product i mean
they're like everywhere i mean let me
talk about your faults if that's all
right let me just ask one more question
sure just
if you have an assembly theory and
computation and all these wonderful
things um could you have a bs detector i
mean could you say you know now now you
feed in some um
some left-handed dna i think that's the
non-uh stereoisomer that occur doesn't
occur in life that we know about so
look what i found you know would this
then tell you
that there there's this there's some
trickery and some jiggery pokery as you
say i mean could could it tell that this
is not and is that instantiated by you
lee did you put in if you see a
left-handed dna helix you know the guy
is a fraud you know tell me how does
that how would that be
it's a sneaky way of asking about the
lab league theory
[Laughter]
well
actually um it's not cheeky it's
actually entirely appropriate
so uh but maybe we don't need to go down
there yeah please i want to stay
monetized
okay good um
i use assembly theory a very crude
version to show
some plagiarism so because because
plagiarism is the ultimate um
kind of you know commendation right and
when
melina trump gave her
presentation to the cup republican
convention
she used a speech which was the same as
michelle obama's speech
and it was like they look the same and i
was like oh wow let's take all the
subjects of the sentences and i broke
them down and with assembly theory be
like you know um on number one i talked
about my you know my my mom my my
country and number two i talked about my
childhood number three i talked about my
dog number three you know you went
through and went wow when i by the time
i got to 14 and a match i knew that that
was plagiarism right because the the
chances of that
not being was like you know 14 factorial
or something right so it was kind of
cool it's like yeah so so you can use it
as a bs detector
and and yes you can use it to look for
genetic material and look for motifs
that are repeating
and and then you can see what
engineering has been done and what
evolution has done and it should be
possible to get get that because entropy
course grains it all out assembly
reassembles it okay so now the next
question will dovetail into what kurt
was just about to ask which is could
there be an analog of assembly theory to
apply to unidentified aerial phenomena
kurt is that is that okay to ask
sure i'd also like to explain re-explain
if you don't mind myself to the audience
and then you can correct my explanation
of assembly theory because it's
extremely important
so
lee cronin has a number it's almost like
kolmogorov complexity so those of you
who know what that is they're different
forms of
of putting a number to a piece of
information to see how complex it is
and what you have in lee's theory is you
have elements that you consider to be
atomic so you can consider those to be
axioms and then you have certain rules
of inference now those rules of
inference are like the laws of physics
though this can also be applied to
mathematics and that's why i think it's
extremely interesting because you can
quantify how difficult a formula is to
prove anyway so you have you have atoms
and then you have rules of inference and
then you wonder what is the minimum
amount of steps to get from the axioms
to the stated formula so for example the
word candy if we consider the letters of
the alphabet to be atomic then the word
candies complexity is five so you think
well that makes sense it's five letters
yeah because step one you pull c out
step two you pull an a out but the word
pom poms which is seven letters is
complexity of five because you p okay
you pull a p out that's step one pull an
o out pull an m out then you need to put
another p but great we have the word
palm already created so that's that step
is taken care of by simply duplicating
the palm so then we have another step
for the s so then that's five in total
now is that a correct summation okay
yeah yeah you'll hive
great you're great okay and and the
reason this is extremely fascinating is
because you can use certain instruments
like mass spectrometry potentially to
assess the complexity of far away
molecules and then you can see well look
h2o maybe has a complexity of four i
don't know maybe five whatever it
doesn't matter two hydrogen one oxygen
but a simple protein may have 400 steps
a simple protein and thus if you can
quantify by looking through a telescope
the complexity of something far away
then perhaps you can say well it was
produced by life it's that correct
yeah yeah i can tell you something quick
and blow your mind don't have to use a
mass spec and use infrared so i came up
with a the brianal like this a
non-gravitationally lensing complexity
cloak what the [ __ ] is that well sorry
for swearing um so you know black holes
are black holes but if you can make an
object that would basically so
in the infrared um
infrared
radiation gets absorbed at specific
lines well all radiation gets specific
lines um but i came up with a way of
making molecules to store binary code of
them because i want to leave a message
for some aliens when the humanity is
about to end and put it in the
atmosphere and what you could do is you
have these like if you were able to say
right i've got all this spectrum and i
want to cover all of it i'm going to
design a molecule absorbs here here here
here here here
and i'll make it super light
there might be objects in the universe
that are non-gravitational lens and
complexity cloaks because they're light
and they can absorb all that energy
across and just re-radiate it some other
way or be used so it's like a it's kind
of like a dyson sphere but it's cooler
because it's it's basically really dark
over everything and and what am i saying
the reason i was saying this to you kurt
not only was your explanation spot on
you're talking about mass spec but you
could also use infrared
um
spectroscopy and a telescope to go and
look for not just life but technology
that basically is showing itself in the
in the infrared and uv and maybe x-ray
whatever
okay great now on to the ufo question
brian when you say that scientists have
an incentive to find life in the
universe and incentives via nobel prize
in money etc i don't buy that per se i
think they have an incentive to find a
certain form of life in the universe but
not life in general and the reason is
that life in general borders on what is
considered to be woo or paranormal for
example if you were to study ufos and
say is there credibility to these these
reports that's almost not done besides a
few individuals like kevin knuth for
example
because i
i i think almost none of us i don't
think any of us are actually pursuing
the truth including myself which is why
i don't like when people say this
channel is for truth seekers almost none
of us care about the truth per se
because the truth can be extremely hard
so we care about it in a certain bounded
fashion so we also care about our
reputations we care about not sounding
like these d in sensate de cerebrate
rednecks which is what the people in the
academy generally think of those who who
consider the ufo reports to be real they
they generally consider them to and
let's be honest they consider them to be
kooks and i think that academics
generally care much more about either
sounding intelligence or not appearing
to be inane
more than they care about the truth per
se
and so it's it's extremely bounded by
their
either place in a social hierarchy by
their place among their peers they don't
want to be ostracized it's anathema to
analyze ufo reports so that's why i say
i don't buy
when
you say that well we have an extreme
incentive to find life in the universe a
certain type of life i agree
yeah well i think uh i think largely
that is accurate although i will say in
my defense you know i did join the
galileo project with our mutual friend
navi loeb uh specifically for this
reason not as a researcher but as a
member of the external oversight board
because i actually don't think they need
my help as an observational astronomer
i'm pretty good but you know harvard is
not exactly hurting for for money and
you know they can certainly raise
funding especially when you have the you
know uh former uh chairman the
longest-serving chairman in harvard's
history in the astronomy department at
the helm who's you know joe rogan's
appearance blew up the internet and uh
has has uh you know number five
bestseller um you know last year in the
new york times list so i don't think
they need my help you know kind of
necessarily doing the research but i do
think they can always use help uh
holding them to account
and you know if i i told this to avi you
know i wouldn't have called it the
galileo project i think it's dangerous
when you know uh astronomers begin
uh by you know kind of bringing up the
names like bruno and and galileo and and
persecuted
figures in history i think that's a
fraught perilous endeavor and i think i
would be even that is sort of a be lying
a bias in other words his his claim is
that just like galileo uh suffered from
and the inability of the powers that be
the funding agencies of this time the
the
venetian dogens and senate and and other
agencies to at first look through in the
catholic church later on to look through
his telescope and and see for themselves
as if that would have proven anything i
mean just looking through a telescope
proves nothing it's the connection of
the human mind and the formulation of a
hypothesis and evidentiary data that
could disconfirm his hypothesis you know
galileo had many blunders kurt
i'm pleased and privileged to be working
with with jim gates carlo revelli frank
wilcheck fabiola giannatti and uh my
good friend from uh from uh graduate
school lucio pichurillo on the first
ever audiobook version of any of
galileo's book and it's oh that's
interesting and i also didn't know that
that was the genesis of the word galileo
in the project i thought it just meant
i'm going to be looking out like galileo
looked down
no no i mean i i think the project's
really dangerous i'd like to kind of
push back on you i mean not push back
i'd like to reassure you i mean i can't
speak for brian just a second just a
second lee i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i
just want brian to finish because i i
interrupted him and then so please
finish brian and then and then leave
kurt's used to me and throw a punch
but uh so we're translating galileo's
book we have the rights to the first
ever audiobook for galileo with a
forward by einstein and uh that's read
by frank wilcheck winner of the nobel
prize in 2004 and jim gates so what does
it say it says galileo was wrote the the
the definitive treatise on the
scientific method on what you're
supposed to do with evidence et cetera
et cetera and yet in that very book he
makes a catastrophic confirmation
blunder at the very end on day four it's
a trialog between these three characters
i'm one of them carlo revelli is another
one and my friend lucio's the other and
we go about and we're trying to disprove
uh uh galileo's character salviacces
trying to disprove uh the uh the the
earth-centered notion of the universe
that's held by simplicio the simpleton
uh who is espousing the words of the
pope uh that the earth is the center of
the universe and then i'm playing
segreto the kind of knowledgeable lay
person who is interpreting between them
and gal is a phenomenal writer but he
goes through and describes these things
in such loving detail that even i become
convinced when he goes about and says
that the tides on the earth are proof
that the earth is going around the sun
that's complete balderdash we know
that's not correct and it would take
newton to do it and his argument is very
simple and persuasive it uses data it
would have gotten accepted by nature
probably if nature had existed not like
you know lee's travails um but his
argument is that you've got this you
know you've got this object that's going
around the sun here's the sun over here
and here we've got tides on the earth
and
as it goes around the sun it orbits and
the tide sloshes around and that's why
we have ti it's totally wrong
the tides are caused by the lunar
gravitational force the tidal force
quadripolar moment of the lunar
gravitational force field nothing to do
with our motion around the sun really
and yet it's incredibly persuasive and
so if you took the lessons of absolute
objective history and you say like
should we have listened to galileo no
you'd throw out that book you throw it
out he says nonsense even though that he
brings up relativity for the first time
in human history the notion of relative
motion does not affect the laws of
nature which we now call lorentz and
variants these are foundational things
and yet the summary of the book is
totally wrong the conclusion of the book
is totally misproven and he didn't use
the best evidence in hand so look for
that coming soon hopefully on galileo's
birthday in february but
this is all to say when it comes to when
it comes to avi's project avi loeb's
project
i think they need oversight more than
they need my insight which is to say
that i think the the first reaction that
we have to have is skepticism because we
do want to believe i think if we all go
back to our 12 year old boys when we
were 12 year old boys forget about
funding and and i'm going to lose my my
my status as a chair professor or lee's
going to lose no we're just little boys
and we're playing with that little
pebble on the beach like ninten said and
we're looking for a shinier pebble if we
were to discover that i mean it raises
the hair in the back of my neck that
there was extraterrestrial intelligence
first life you know i i have my
misgivings i've talked to lee about that
we'll talk about that some other but
just about slime mold on the planet
enceladus or the moon enceladus i don't
think that will make as big an impact as
lee does but let's leave that aside
let's just talk about ufos i
don't want to believe i want to have
evidence and i think if you if you bury
your head in the sand you won't get
evidence so i have to say
and i hope this is true of avi too uh
that we are kind of the boy the 12 year
old boys sitting on the on the bed not
being able to fall asleep at night
looking up at the stars we do want to
know the truth but we want to have
evidence for it as mature men as
scientists at this very moment so anyway
lee you were going to say you've got
some problems with with uh with the
project and i'm happy again i don't
speak for them i'm on their external
advisory committee i think it's
important to do but i am predisposed
it's like the bets that stephen hawking
used to make with kip thorne he would
bet against hawking radiation ever being
you know validated and so that if he
lost the bet you know he'd have the
thrill of intellectual superiority being
correct
uh so what say you lee
yeah i mean it's no big it's no big deal
i'm i think i'm i've got a lot of
sympathy for kurt's position
or kind of
um worry about where we are as
scientists look for ufos but i think
that
i know avi very well he's great but he's
playing a very strange game here i would
like to say he's kind of saying oh the
scientific establishment's not ready for
this i'm a genuine cantarian and i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna basically come
up with these things i'm being ignored
no he's just making stuff up right
making stuff up what is he making up a
theo location with leon cronin and avilo
is about to be booked we got a plan
yeah so what i mean by is making stuff
up he's making up a
false argument about um
that people are kind of you know when it
comes to this interstellar object that
came through and he was just he was
saying why it could be alien space junk
sure it could be all sorts of things but
it but we were trying to understand
what the characteristics of trajectory
was telling us so he's kind of making up
stories which are fine i don't mean he's
fabricating stuff i mean he's saying a
narrative
and i'm wondering why
is he making that narrative what does he
have to gain
other than some kind of you know fame
and notoriety and i'm going to be
downtrodden by the establishment because
if i suddenly said to brian hey brian
we've just found wormholes i saw it over
there look wormhole over there wormhole
over there wormhole over there and and
then brian says lee you've haven't got
any wormholes you just may you know you
haven't got any date and i'll be like
you're just beating me up big professor
you know and i think it's a bit like
this so well i i'm really glad that
brian that is kind of borderline ad
hominem lee i have to point that out i
mean i love avi i fight with avi but but
that seems like imputing his impugning
his character almost you can
disassociate yourself from it what i'm
trying to say to so it's not clipped out
of context is that i like the idea of
searching
but i there is this so what i'm trying
to say there's this cultural vibe going
on right now our culture is changing
people are asking questions what are
these things that the pentagon has
released what is the probability of us
this happening
and and i'm saying that we don't
we could play together i would love to
help avi be successful i it doesn't i
don't think it's a
we i don't think the establishment is
against him i don't think even i'm in
the establishment nor brian we genuinely
want to know
and i do agree with you that there is
some
we are putting we could put our careers
on the line if we get it wrong but
actually in science you have become
better scientists the more you're wrong
and what i'm saying here is abby's
adopting an extreme viewpoint where he
may not allow himself to be wrong and
it's not an ad hominem i'm not saying
he's anything bad i'm not saying he's
doing anything dishonest i'm saying he's
making a narrative well let's be precise
so i had him on my show
and it was a wonderful episode and this
is long before i decided to join
and i said avi i don't believe that you
believe this is real that this
is an
to have access extraterrestrial a
resource that's highly complex has a lot
of uh
has a lot of assembly behind it called
yuri milner who is a russian billionaire
and he's showered upon uh you the
potential as a leader of the
breakthrough starshot uh prize one of
the leaders uh there's a tremendous
resource so instead of sending you know
10 to the fourth uh cell phone cameras
to proxima century b
why don't you send one of them at you
know not even half the speed of light
not even ten percent of the speed of
just you know three four percent of this
people and catch up to omumu you know
what he said he said no no we don't need
to do that because when ruben telescope
which is the vera rubin uh uh
observatory in chile which is going to
be a phenomenal instrument it's designed
it was the original name was the
large-scale synoptic
survey telescope to survey the whole sky
with a huge cadence very quickly looking
for objects that are anomalous that
could do and he says that's one of the
dream machines for discovering we
already discovered one of them using pan
stars on hawaii um so we're gonna
discover millions of these things i said
well avi you know i don't know if you
know about this but you know like uh you
know sometimes you know
things happen only once you know there's
an n of one problem that we talk about
and what if this yeah what if they are
abundant and what if there are forces
that conspire against in our solar
system just particularly not to the
cosmos to our solar system maybe the
lunar you know so tidal solar whatever
whatever it is um and it makes these
objects very very unlikely to ever be
seen again even though they're abundant
wouldn't you want to catch up to the
only one with all the resources you have
and he was sort of agnostic about it
that gave me some pause and that's one
of the things i'm going to push back on
as an external advisor but i i would you
know and i love you lee but but i don't
think he's doing it for fam i mean he
has an ego that's well known um he's he
has trouble controlling um you know
sometimes his passions for what he does
i think he's doing an incredible
valuable service but i just want to talk
about from the perspective as an
observational astronomer can
observational astronomers provide
information in the way that you've been
using it
about this phenomenon uh in other words
we survey the sky in all wavelength
bands 24 7 around the earth from
antarctica where i've been twice for two
months of my life uh and uh to the north
pole to space now we've got jwst um what
would it convince a believer
to
give up the uh the expectations in other
words carl sagan said lack of evidence
is not evidence of absence or absence of
evidence so we can't but we can't we
also have to admit we have conserved
resources and finite time which is the
most prominent of all reasons
let me just come in quickly so i
completely agree we're all characters
right and i know avid is great
all i'm trying to say is um we i want
him to help i want him to succeed so
exactly i think my the only thing i
would comment here say how can we help
you let's help let's help you do this
right whatever you think the narratives
are it's capturing the day i do think we
have a responsibility though and it's
not an ad holmen it is kind of a bit way
in this polarization in the time of
covid elections we do have a
responsibility for correctly framing the
argument so we're not leading people
down the guard up the garden path that's
the only point i'm getting at mean being
too optimistic or being too high
salesman yeah exactly exactly that's all
i mean nothing else everything else is
good so what i would say to avi is like
how can we help you what i would say to
kurt it's like
what do you think
science science mainstream science is
doing enough of you're finding
frustrating because you know i'm i'm a
i'm a cheap scientist in the regard
i want to know why i'm in the universe i
want to know why i'm here i want to have
meaning
if there are aliens out there i want to
know it's not just the right type of
alien any will do me
any evidence um and and i
talk about that
getting meaning from science and meaning
from life in the universe that might
have to be a part two uh curve but but
anyway yeah i know we both want want we
want evidence right we don't want to
just you know just marginally and we
only have finite amount of time and
intellectual time but don't forget you
know our forgetting curve you know
speaking i can tell you from experience
in a few years you're gonna have trouble
remembering your kids names and you know
hopefully you know uh that'll stop but
uh but but we only have so much time for
attention to pay attention to things of
of of great import to us so i i you know
i guess the the subject is what what
else should we be doing we being
astronomers avi's not going to build you
know a a large hadron collider squared
you know look for uh interdimensional
aliens you know manipulating wormholes
to get here right he's an astronomer
he's a theorist by the way he's not an
observer so so i think he needs help uh
i think the the you know having you
involved you know from that perspective
but then how do we translate the
signatures from assembly from you know
can be how do we translate that into an
actionable metric that will allow us to
reduce our uncertainty getting back to
our rubric at the beginning of this
conversation
well let me answer
one direct thing i think we can do this
with image data and time series data and
one of the things that would be very
interesting is like if you take any
given image on this dimensionality and
let's say i mean kurt you've got
assembly in one second it's brilliant
right you can apply the same thing to
two dimensional images and also time
series images of course you have to
define your axioms precisely like when
you're looking at how this image image
can be created it's very rare you see
like a straight edge in nature it just
doesn't happen right so you're looking
for yeah i mean and so i i think that's
right and i i what i would say um kurt
quickly is
i've looked at these pentagon images and
i spoke to someone who was responsible
for releasing some of them and i was
like are you just trying to basically
are you just were you bored one day or
did you need more funding or something
why did you do it they were like no
actually we genuinely think
public paid for this data in a way and
we're just throwing it out there so what
i when i try to get out of them what
they thought they wouldn't tell me so
what do you think of these images i mean
you must have i've looked at them i've
listened to people on podcasts on joe
rogan's podcast in particular and looked
at the data and there's all this
mischaracterization of different people
looking at different data sets and
saying things like there's this object
that i think brian you've talked about
this this this this uh this tic-tac that
went from supposedly you know um very
high up to 50 feet off the ocean in like
a second um
but kurt you've had a look at this data
what do you think of it do you think
it's compelling or or are you frustrated
about the quality or
what what is your opinion i think it's
sad that people
hold these as
as evidence of ufos because i don't
think
they are necessarily i think that
they're extremely poor evidence and what
about sightings what about what about
eyewitnesses
that's why all of it has to be looked at
so when someone if someone is to tell me
that bigfoot exists and i ask for
footage and then they show me some
pixelated video i don't think that
that's great evidence for bigfoot now
that in tandem with a variety of stories
from people who we would think of as
credible in any other situation that in
tandem with let's say a rape trial we
would send someone to jail based on two
or three witness testimonies
and yet we have a team of people who are
extremely credible who testify to the
strangeness of this phenomenon and then
we don't we think well perhaps their
eyes are misleading them well i don't
think that's reasonable
so i think it's strange i don't find any
single one of the videos to be
compelling i find the set of videos to
be somewhat compelling that there's
something strange happening but i find
the total set of
i i'm putting evidence in scare culture
evidence of ufos to be
interesting and i also don't believe
that we want to believe in ufos i know
that you said that brian i know
well
i want to believe in i want to have
evidence yeah yeah well you also
mentioned that we have this need to
believe in external life and i don't
think that's true for me personally i
hope that all of what's happening with
ufos is false well lee said something
sorry kurt
well i'm just afraid of the implications
and i think that anyone who seriously
thinks about this perhaps should be
because it may indicate that we're not
at the top of the food chain it may mean
that we don't mean what we think we mean
in terms of our place in the universe
our purpose even i feel the same way
about the prospects of hell i don't want
to believe in hell not that i do but i
don't want to believe in it in some ways
i don't want to believe in god in some
ways i find comfort in that
consciousness ends so there are so many
beliefs that people say well people have
a need to believe in in god people have
a need to believe in ufos some do some
don't and i think that if you seriously
thought about ufos perhaps
perhaps you would want to believe that
they don't exist when i say ufos i mean
obviously ufos exist the alien life
that's supposedly behind it is what i'm
referring to
well i think that exemplifies why you're
one of the best in the business kurt and
what you do on this on this channel uh
and that you have uh this you know kind
of uh humility epis epistemological
humility uh but you also have a tenacity
and that is a rare combination um i
think you know one one nice place maybe
to wrap up and then
you know lee is often
i claim in a good sense you know my
belief fundamentally is that no one's an
atheist
everyone has a religion you know for
some even that don't go to you know
church or synagogue you know that
religion as i documented my first book
losing the nobel prize it is often the
nobel prize and this is kind of a kosher
idol you know that yeah it doesn't cause
that much harm and yeah funding
decisions are made and you know lee's
mentioned it more times than i have
today and it's obviously you know top of
mind for many scientists and and i
zygosen hopefully he would win it i
don't have anything against the people
that win it i've interviewed a dozen of
them on my show but on the other hand um
you know there even lack of a religion
secularism um i think that there is a
religion of scientism which is that uh
science can provide meaning and i i'd
like to push back on that i'd like to
explore what lee and you think kurt
about this very notion in other words uh
the word science in in in
in in greek uh means knowledge it
doesn't mean wisdom you know sapien
means wisdom you know one who knows that
he knows sapianism i talked about this
lex friedman on the podcast just came
out and look forward by the way to lee
cronin who inspired me you know to to
you know get connected to lex again uh
you know lex uh hosted lee before me and
uh lee helped me prepare a lot for my
episode because he was on lex's show and
he'll hopefully have that episode out
soon too might have been allegedly we
know i can't wait to see that one but
you know i talked about this you know
that that i don't get any meaning from
science i i think scientist science is
intrinsically inherently you know we may
have curiosity and the motto of my
channel is abc always be curious
but curiosity and wisdom don't
necessarily go together and i documented
many times you know nobel laureates that
were nazis you know and had great
knowledge and used their knowledge of of
of chemicals and you know forefathers
yeah fritz haber you know leak
way more engineered but yeah yeah yeah
it's evil you know and he was a jew and
his and his and his uh his icon b
eventually led to the gassing of many of
his own family members so anyway don't
look to science for wisdom so if you
can't look it to it for wisdom
why do we look to it for meaning
so lee
i can i can give you a quick answer but
maybe it's your show where do you want
to go first yeah here's what i suggest i
suggest that we take a bathroom break
and then brian you check with your wife
see if it's okay if you keep talking for
a little while longer and leave with
whoever you have to speak to as well
because there are some audiences he has
to talk to the queen there are some
audience questions we haven't gotten to
oh yeah i'd like to get to those
all right yeah yeah i've got i've got 25
minutes this just in my wife says 25
more months
i'll take a two-minute break yeah yeah
and also quickly before we go so lee do
you have anything to promote i'll make
this transition smooth once we edit this
do you oh
like a podcast channel or something
no i'm i'm i'm i i i'm pr i promote
house you're on a clubhouse a lot i mean
i i what am i promoting i'm i think that
um
i just want people to kind of ask more
questions and unfray in in an unframed
way and know that they can get framed
you know
i
i have
for me we'll talk about when we come
back from break but i genuinely love
not knowing and then finding a little
dent and then getting something yeah
it's like climbing a hill okay so yeah
the answer is no he doesn't have
anything but you should
you should go and look at that
i need to go to the toilet as well yeah
yeah because i wanted to just promote
right now and then let's go to the
washroom so people can click on this so
brian has losing the nobel prize as a
book you also have into the impossible
which is a book as well as a podcast and
the links are in the description i have
purchased both of them
additionally brian your interview with
lex friedman just came out either today
or yesterday so that's fresh and lee you
have a ted talk and
i believe i believe an upcoming lex
freeman podcast interview hopefully
allegedly i'm not saying anything
brian's building not me on lex's podcast
we have alex has an image of me and lee
talking on my podcast so it's definitely
coming out people who are watching just
click on those links and look up
lee and brian's
work see you soon
yeah back in a minute
you should know that
releasing in just a couple hours is the
stephon alexander interview and that one
we talk about matrix models and string
theory it's super interesting look
forward to that it's premiering in about
three
hours stefan alexander coincidentally or
perhaps not coincidentally is one of
brian keating's best friends if not his
best friend so are you at home are you
at the office
this is my home office oh i'm actually
i'm actually in fact in there in the
corner there
that is the cellular automata running in
3d in my led cube that's interesting in
fact it's conway's game of life
um
you've incorrectly implemented boundary
conditions because i'm rubbish at that
quite interesting okay
my lab is moving the next we're in
glasgow i'm in the old in the chemistry
department which is a lovely old
building
but it's not quite fit for purpose and
i'm moving my team onto a new floor
and we've got um
all these fume hoods all kitted out for
the digital camera history kit
so the dream
experiment that i wanted to build
10 years ago
will be constructed
in march
and we have the assembly meter
so you never know
by april 2024 we might have the answer
or an answer but
uh yeah so but i've started doing a lot
of work at home obviously with covid
we all been trapped but now kovid is
almost hopefully cross whatever unless
unless the person who wrote covet i'm
joking
has updated the firmware
i saw that on so it's like there's lots
of jokes at the moment about that
you know the problem with you know i was
listening some of your jokes brian but
was it someone about the problem of
vomicron if we don't solve it now
you know what comes after omnicron
is pi and that just goes on forever ah
that's hilarious
who said that
oh it was on a it was on a podcast i
heard a uk political podcast um
called the bunker
so all the load of left wingers we what
we're sad about brexit oh i mean i'm sad
about brexit but i have no politics here
okay so let's get to some audience
questions
also well another time we can talk about
free will in time
we started
we can solve time consciousness and free
will in one easy podcast
[Laughter]
okay well briefly quickly
lee when you said that time is
fundamental i don't know if you actually
said that but when you you were talking
about entropic time is what we normally
think of as physicists as
as precipitating the arrow of time
and you're saying that well that may be
the wrong way of going about it so are
your views more aligned with lee because
lee believes time to be fundamental
but briefly lee if you don't mind i'm
sorry he hasn't least yeah yeah sorry
yeah yeah well so i first met lee smolin
and i told him my theory thomas oh
that's my theory and i'm like wow our
names are both lee
yeah so i mine is slightly more dramatic
and remember i'm a professional idiot
regis idiot and what i mean by that is
that um i don't get confined by
discipline boundaries so it was when i
first told sarah my theory of time she
was just like this is just can't be true
you know this is just but all i'm saying
is that there is no such thing as space
there is time okay
and from and time creates space right in
some mechanism that we don't really
understand
and um that breaks in everything we need
i tried to argue with sean carroll about
this but he didn't even argue he said no
you're just wrong i was like why he said
well my theory is better time can go
forward and backwards and i'm like that
breaks causality so time is primal time
creates space
and
um and the the
there is a finite amount of time that
has existed in our current universe
right that doesn't mean there aren't
things outside our universe and uh and
it works a bit like that and that's why
assembly
helps us quantify that through assembly
is almost like looks at the degree of
asymmetry since the beginning of time
that's recorded but i can i can budge on
some of it but that's it in two or three
sentences yeah we'll talk about that
we'll perhaps have another podcast and
so people who are watching if you have
questions for brian and or lee leave
them below okay brian do you have any
quick comments on the nature of time
before we get to the questions from the
audience
well i think you know time again is one
of these things that you know we kind of
know it when we see it it's it's like
you know what does it
feel like to be a bat you know nagel's
question you know it's always just like
we don't know
and i find that uh
sort of interpretable in the sense of we
know it when we feel it we know it when
we see it we have biological clocks
we're turning grayer and grey kurt
doesn't know that yet uh but but someday
he will
uh we take comfort that his uh
diminution and beauty will only only
catch up to us well you look like buzz
lightyear man like that's a huge
compliment someone in the lex comments
said that and i thought man that's
exactly right and you're an astronomer
as well and lee you're a great looking
guy yeah i remember when i saw you i'm
like this is a good looking guy
i don't want to be in the same podcast
absolutely
you're a good-looking guy too brian yeah
thank you very much but that means he
lives in a bubble you know you're power
more you're a powerful looking guy brian
i'd say that
thank you thank you i do have a strong
aroma well well i'd rather be
okay
so time you know i had talked about this
with frank wilczyk on on my into the
impossible podcast i said what is time
you know just like i asked lee what is
life um yeah i asked uh other people
helping philip goff on i'll ask him what
is consciousness you know it's like we
know it when we see it frank said to me
will chuck said you know time is what
clock's mentioned all right thanks a lot
you know yeah but anything could be a
clock so i think what's interesting is
to pursue the path that lee has pursued
uh you know what is the simplest mall
you know chemical that can form
with with inspiration with direction
towards evolutionary purposes and he has
simulations that you can see in his ted
talk about it's brilliant um i think
there's an experiment done at nist and
i'm going to have nicole halpern younger
on who's a brilliant scientist at nist
in maryland and she has a new book
called quantum steampunk which is really
delightful kind of in the vein of a
roger penrose emperor's new new mind
in which she talks about you know what
is the world's simplest clock and on my
channel i make explainer videos and one
i did is what is time and and how can
you understand time um by making the
world's simplest clock and what is a
clock something that ticks okay well
what is something that takes well has
quantum states and i think the
revolution that uh would be interesting
for another podcast maybe lee and and
kurt will come on my podcast maybe with
avi loeb we can have a knock down drag
out a conversation lee smallin just get
everybody in there mosh pit
is to talk about well what are the
quantum implications you know there's
quantum thermodynamics that's coming to
the front things like silard entropy and
stuff that lee knows about that i'm just
learning about i think these are all
really fruitful and i wonder how that
could feed into things that lee is
working on but yeah for now maybe um you
want to talk about uh meaning from
science or do you want to talk audience
questions i want to do i want to make
sure that we answer all the audience
questions yeah let's get to the audience
so this one comes from
sneaky toaster
questions my kids that was my first
choice for my middle child's middle name
so the question is eric weinstein and
others are advocating for the
irrefutable data the government has on
uap's ufos to be released to the science
community should the science community
be granted access
well i i've pushed back with uh respect
to eric i've told them on clubhouse
chats on my you know what what do you
mean like the data like data is the data
the hubble deep field like if there are
aliens you know in the universe then you
know there's 10 to the fifth or 10th of
the fourth galaxies in the hubble ultra
deep field then you know there's
probably an awful lot of aliens in there
you know go go for it but but but i
wonder you know is that really true
there's data again the hubble deep field
tells you exactly one thing as far as i
can tell maybe it tells you a little bit
more it allows you to estimate with
about 50 uncertainty and again the issue
is not the error is not the value that
is measured the mantissa you know it is
the error bars that's where the science
comes in i can measure something even i
could go into lee's lab and make some
chemical reactions and you know i'd
probably make ho2 or you know whatever i
screw up everything i i joke that when i
did biology i would dissect the frog the
frog would live i'm terrible at these
wet sciences but the error bars that's
where the scientist comes out and i
think unless you tell me what is your
way of doing what's called a blind
analysis here's an example with my
telescopes i measure data i measure data
from the big bang the origin of the
universe the origin of the elements
called the cosmic microwave background
radiation if i make an observation of
the polarization looking for waves of
gravity that could indicate the presence
of an early exponential phase of
inflationary expansion which is you know
surely could garner many many accolades
and satiate our knowledge
of perhaps all of the conjectures about
things called the multiverse well if i
do that
and i make a claim i have to show that
that data is immune from dust
but i also have to show that the data i
got on tuesday is the same as the data i
got on wednesday and that the data i got
when the telescope was slewing to the
left at four degrees per second it's the
same as the one and slew to the right at
four degrees for a second that's a
critical sorry i was gonna start
to interrupt but i i want to frame
something here because this is almost
getting why i was saying about avi
earlier and also
um er what eric is saying is that when
he says show us the data it's almost
like there's like he's kind of invoking
some kind of conspiracy and stuff and
there's all these you know little green
men and what brian's just really
precisely is i know what we want to know
is at this spot on earth at this time
when this was happening what was
happening show a show and show us so
we've got a comparable data control
sorry to interrupt you brian but i think
it's really important that we because we
we're both eye to eye on this yeah
the point is you have to tell me ahead
of time when i do an analysis we have to
show in a blind analysis what the error
bar will get for a variety of different
scenarios until you tell me i might give
you data but until you tell me and
actually we don't even do it because
it's a tremendous amount of work for us
to process data in a way that another
person could come in to understand
calibration flat fielding spectral
spectral line uh flat um dark currents
all the things that go into just imaging
and imaging is simple compared to
measuring the cmb uh just in terms of
like these detectors have been around 40
years longer than the type of detectors
that i'm working with um i'm not saying
it's easier or harder globally or more
important but the bottom line is i have
to my student has to tell me how she's
going to analyze the data and how she's
going to assess the final error bar long
before we unblind and let her see the
results so tell me how could you
mistakenly interpret in the image which
i don't think is really as probative as
spectral data or radar data whatever but
let's just stipulate it as tell me how
you're going to interpret to guard
against as feynman said you fooling
yourself and you everyone i'm looking at
you out there you are the easiest person
to fool i'm happy to share data and i'll
advocate for you
about getting data out of the galileo
project however you have to do some
legwork too you can't say oh they're
hiding it from me therefore they're
hiding something forever no
tell me what you're going to do with it
tell me how you're going to prove
yourself wrong and so that i will say to
you you are my fellow scientist even
though you may not have a phd
okay this was a live chat question
someone wants to know lee tom poliska
tom poleski asks lee why hasn't your
seti experiment with spectrograph in the
infrared been done by anyone yet
because i happen to have a big mouth and
like all the stuff happening in the lab
i always talk about fraud publish it but
the paper's almost finished and when
people said to me you couldn't possibly
get assembly number on my spectator and
we did i think but we can do it with a
thing called nmr nuclear magnetic
resonance and infrared and we've just
done it and we've proved it works so i
very much hope that once we get this out
there that we will put out enough um
data and and the algorithm required for
people to start an experiment indeed
there are people who are going to be
getting um spectroscopy uh especially
spectroscopic data from out the solar
system which want to try with try this
with but we need to be cautious because
the resolution is really so poor there's
limited amount of things we can do but
my dream would be to put a spectrometer
an infrared spectrometer in in orbit
above venus there's a lot of and maybe
one in orbit maybe in titan and we could
do exactly that experiment so it's a
really good point and literally assembly
theory was kind of invented last year
we published the paper the experiment
the mass effect paper in may
we've been working on several theory
papers and more experimental paper and
that's just coming so yeah it's really
literally hot off the press so it's not
made up it works but i just need to
literally get it into a pre-print in
publication and i'm talking to various
organizations that may or may not have
lots of money and may or may not have
lots of maybe private and public that
are planning missions
and um and i'm advocating very strongly
for us to do that
send send a telescope they can do
infrared spectroscopy all around the
solar system and map the assembliness
everything
okay this question comes from visin
cosman this is to both of you ask all of
your materialistic guests to give one
single example of something outside of
consciousness
uh i think there are
great difficulties in doing that simply
because we are
the ghost in the machine that is
defining a what consciousness is what
our experiences what is materialistic or
not i should say that you know i'm much
more
much less materialistic than i assume
lee is i know he is i don't know so much
about kurt but i'd love to know more uh
in that there are um what i usually talk
about is you know are there is there
permission to believe not not the proof
i said this on lex's pocket like i don't
care if i believe in god you know like
does god need me does god care about
brian keating who gives a
um you know maybe maybe if god believes
in me you know if god exists but the
question of whether or not you i'm a
behaviorist so i think that people
manifest how they behave uh the
underlying uh consciousness that they
are internalized have that they have
internalized is is manifest externally
by their behaviors so i look to things
like religion in a very practical sense
uh can this give um can this give
community can this give a purpose can
this without necessarily accepting the
reality
as provable in a scientific context i
don't think you can prove or disprove
and i give upgrade my religious friends
too
i say if you don't learn science
you're you're basically just you know
kind of living in this in this bubble if
you don't learn because science may
actually bolster your faith
as i said you know lexis podcast i'll
i've said other places you know what if
the fact that we can perceive an
infinite spectrum of colors an infinite
diversity of life an infinite number of
tastes and you know dimensionality of
what it could be otherwise and the fact
that the universe is extravagant
is potentially
a clue a symbol uh a talisman i'm not
saying it's proof of course because i
don't think there can be proof
but um but i think those are sort of a
non-materialistic but again it's
materialistic and a reductionist sense
because i do believe that you can
practice it for your own benefit you can
you can glean wisdom from it you can
glean experience community charity
things that improve you stoicism you
know i'm one of the few people i read
the christian bible every day in the
jewish bible every day i read the stoics
the ancient greeks the romans
these are things that i think broaden
your mind whether you believe it has to
be true or not
um so i'm more of a pragmatist i would
say in terms of what consciousness
things could not be explainable via
science
i'm going to ask you one more time
simply so can you point to something
that exists outside consciousness
what would you say i can i i would say
there's lots of things exist outside
consciousness but i think we have to do
that doing that null experiment is hard
right
i think that the causal chain that gave
gave rise to how chemistry so i'm going
to give the boring answer but i think
that um the
the
the process of evolution in the universe
and selection exists outside
consciousness because it had to invent
consciousness i would be interested to
know if computation is a fundamental
thing in the universe that didn't need
to go through consciousness
that's an interesting question but my my
simple answer is i think that a lot of
you the universe exists outside of
consciousness but i will never
really
convincingly be able to prove it because
i am a conscious entity
just to make it clear because i want to
make sure this person doesn't write in
the comments say they equivocated what
is one example of something that is
outside consciousness
i think understanding consciousness i
think the meta problem of
you know what is it like to be a bat how
do you how do you separate in the heart
you know david charles is coming on my
show in a couple weeks i'll certainly
ask him this question oh you're saying
yeah you're saying something beyond
conscious comprehension intrinsically
right is that what
i think here's what the person is
getting at let's imagine i say x is
outside consciousness well that x
appears to you in your own consciousness
so it's not technically outside
consciousness now you can think maybe it
can exist besides me outside of me but
even that itself is an idea within
consciousness the easy answer right and
i think brian well i mean i know i think
brian might agree with this is like i'm
not
i think that
um the ground truth for quantum
mechanics appears to be outside of
consciousness because quantum mechanics
wasn't constructed of conscious beings
and then we get all those and it's shown
by you know there are people who are
closets many worlds people right
and they get really stuck another thing
is that before that
i can
imagine
that there might be something outside of
the universe that is entirely separate
to this universe i can imagine it
but i just but i there is something
beyond my imagination because clearly
what can it be right i mean i could say
this is really like me saying i can
imagine all the set of prime numbers but
i can't tell you what the next one is
and that's really important so i think
there are things outside of that
intrinsically outside of consciousness
and
and um and i think that we have to be
humble because i think even if we think
we could nail everything
i mean actually i'm i'm not religious
right but i have a great deal of respect
for uh religious people i do not like
the approach that richard dawkins and
lawrence krauss take to people who have
religion and say they're stupid because
they're not they have belief
and i have beliefs and my beliefs are
kind of a bit boring but i do have
beliefs and one of the reasons why i get
a buzz out of science is um i'm taking
something in my belief box and putting
it into my
fact box and it's not that i'm trying to
disprove god but it's like i'm going
through this process of actually
understanding more about the universe
the more in all of it and the more i
know there's more belief and so i don't
think ever again that's the answer so i
think of course intrinsically there must
be things i think is this provable i
think we would need to get a proper
philosopher who would take us through
the thought processes and understanding
how it set up the axioms and the
argument but i believe my crude answer
would be probably almost yes there's
lots outside of our consciousness
okay this question comes from david's
and it's directed toward you lee but you
can comment on it as well
brian in what sense does lee think that
we need new laws for life like extra
stuff at the fundamental level or some
emergent higher level type of stuff
well um i've already said it i think
that so not new laws necessarily but i
think that i well i would say that we we
can get rid of some laws get rid of the
second law and account for it correctly
so i think there's a new law needed
there so we have to remove the second
law we have to deal with the fact that
we require order at the beginning again
get rid of the second law have time so i
i don't think there's a the nice thing
about this is it's provable it's gonna
be experimentally tractable so i'm not
saying we need to tear up all the rules
i'm just saying that newtonian mechanics
um
is um not appropriate and and i think i
would say something very
very crisp here and i i'm so this very
i think lee smolin has the same idea
that everything in the universe every
object and every event is unique because
it has a unique place in the universe
as i said to the person we talked about
earlier when i went to austin i flew to
austin i've been austin before and i
flew back to london
i've been to those places before but
i've no i've never been there before
because the planet in a different place
in our solar system and our solar
systems are a different part in space
and so i think that we need to
understand that time is not reversible
and that physicists should stop be given
a free get out a jail card we're
allowing time travel because i think
there's cheating causality so i would
say ask that question is that we need to
be clear about causation from
quarks
all the way up to you know from rocks to
rachmaninoff so i think yes we need a
new formulation of the laws but it's not
magic it's just reframing
brian
well i would say they're
um it's poetic it's their certain
romanticism about what lee's talking
about i think strictly speaking you know
i don't i always say you know cosmology
is the one specialization of physics
that doesn't require biology you know
it's like almost everything else yeah
to instantiate itself um or perhaps the
other way around i didn't never make use
of when i teach my undergraduates say
you're going to learn thermodynamics
electromagnetism nuclear physics
particle physics but you're not going to
learn anything about biophysics or you
know you'll even learn some chemistry
right we'll talk a little bit about the
formation of the chemical elements
but that being said i don't think that
there's anything
to learn about g minus two of the muon
or of uh sterile neutrinos or you know
from a new interpretation that involves
life i think you know much much like i
joke about this like string theory is
the best theory ever made to describe
problems in string theory in other words
there will be new technology there'll be
new
um you know uh the new new kind of tools
uh that could be used new tactics to
approach the the problem the essence of
life and don't forget erin schrodinger
recently canceled by the way did you
hear about that the schrodinger's been
canceled um uh finally uh for for some
uh sexual improprieties uh that are
quite awful if true
uh but the bottom line is uh no i don't
think that to understand um that there
may be additional forces and fields
gauge bosons and so forth at the in the
standard model there probably certainly
are i don't know um and uh but but i
don't think that those will necessitate
or require uh uh the conceptions of life
to be uh emergent within them
so i pushed back to brian slightly i
want to push for i agree with what from
brian said but i think he's kind of
causation physics doesn't have causation
at this in in the standard model in the
core models we call it and that is a big
error and i am really certain very
strongly with some courage and humility
that i think that we need to add that in
and i think brian correct me if i'm
wrong because we kind of left the ring
now we're kind of like we've we've i
don't know it's a draw or there was a
who went on point but i would say that
really um we do need causation at the
beginning
um
then that is that that shouldn't be that
shouldn't be because when i speak to
frank we'll check about it he just
he just i mean i have speaking to him
about it and he was very
very good he's very smart he's a bit
cheeky you know you should do this and
some people get prizes for that and i
was like it's just a prize dude who
cares
tell me if causation is at the beginning
and i couldn't
work on it you know i mean there are
people that talk about the causal you
know the structure joe amagio lee smolin
stephan alexander is the going to be on
soon on on this very podcast so yeah no
i agree um i would i would you know
maybe maybe just just kind of rectify my
comment by saying i don't
personally have much you know faith and
say the wolf rami and which is the most
kind of like life like you know at least
in terms of complexity
and rules and algorithmically computable
um essence that that will you know make
concrete astrophysical predictions that
laws will emerge from it um and maybe it
may be that you know understanding life
allows us to understand artificial
intelligence which then allows us to
make up new laws i'm also kind of a ai
minimalist but but that's really a
podcast for another time because i would
just think that the wife and kids will
come and get me soon kurtz okay so then
this is the last one and it relates to
what you said about causation okay why
is this this is from kamar 910 why is
there something rather than nothing and
lee when you say causation so physicists
obviously study causal structures like
brian mentioned but those usually mean
you're within the light cone and it's as
simple as that not this caused this so
when you have a model of causation which
i'm unsure how one can formulate that
how does that not lead to an infinite
regress or either an uncaused cause that
at some point especially if you consider
time to be fundamental uh which ties
into why is there something rather than
nothing which is kamar's question
yeah let me give you two cent summaries
so the theory paper i'm just finishing
with sarah right now actually tackles
that very question
and and it's accept that there are there
at the beginning there is no causation
and but that causation gets baked in
when when information can be stored
about the past that can affect something
differently in the future and it's
really as simple as that and the only
reason physicists have missed it is
because they call screen it out
so all i'm asked all i'm slightly asking
for is to remove entropy
change it to assembly have time going
forward
and suddenly you do have causal cones
and those causal cones actually are
limited by the light cone and i think
that brian and i one day will be talking
about assembly cosmology and we'll be
looking for those artifacts out there
but i think we're we're a little bit far
away from that i need to prove the
theory do the experiments get the data
show the error convince peers
because right now it's just a kind of
cool idea a bit like lots of things in
string theory and you get that
mathematical structure in reality and i
think we'll be able to but we'll have to
be held account on that so it's a really
good question um but i'm pretty sure i
know where it is
what we're doing right i'm also going to
re-ask you leave so you can expound some
more but brian has to go so brian please
uh so again the question from kumar
again is why is there something rather
than nothing okay so what i thought lee
might say is the why questions are kind
of anathema even though they're the most
interesting questions and the most
natural questions my my toddler will ask
me why why why and of course lee is a
parent kurt doesn't know this yet
because he's not a dad yet but please
god you'll be a father soon
kurt you and your lovely wife but lee
knows the ultimate causal chain with an
infinite series of why questions lee how
do we answer our kids
i guess so i mean i just say just tell
them to to look for themselves or to
shut up asking the question right the
answer why why why why why why why why
why because i said so okay there is a
white witness
because i said so but look you have a
point you have an origin
and you have a cause and effect now the
infinite regress isn't infinite what
happens is this is i just don't want to
this is the mechanism selection so what
this person just leaves i'm
brian has to go and i'm going to talk to
you about so you can keep talking about
that but after brian goes i i know what
it's like to have a wife that wants you
no no i mean mine too i think lee is is
is is correct and i do want to see this
and and maybe i'll talk with sarah about
that when she comes on my show
but um but ultimately why questions are
not necessarily part of what scientists
should do why implies a meaning and i
think meaning you know it will bring up
questions of you know teleological
implications uh and i i don't mean that
they're necessarily anathema but usually
when people ask why they mean how or
what um you know how did how did the
causal chain get established uh those
have great answers in in cosmology as
well except they have great problems too
and great mysteries and lee alluded to
three hours ago now almost which was you
know how did the whole thing get kicked
off and and what was the initial
generation of you know a universe and
and so forth you could ask why is there
a universe but i think that the question
of of of why first of all could be
trivial if it didn't exist we wouldn't
be here asking why it doesn't exist
and uh and and there's your whiskey
that's wonderful i wish i could have
some scottish some scottish coffee at
this time of the day um but uh but in
reality
in cosmology as kurt now you and i
talked you know i only i only have one
regret when it comes to careers that i
was on his channel when it had the
square root of the number of viewers
that it does now and it deserves the
square of the number or if not more uh
but but we talked about briefly you know
what are the laws of physics are they
so-called geodesically complete can we
extrapolate the laws and chain of
causality within the light cone when you
have a singularity and lee mentioned
singularity a few times i happen to not
to believe that there is a quantum
theory of gravity at least i don't
believe is as well motivated i think
physicists get distracted by it i think
that they're pursuing the theory of
everything for the grandeur the glory
the the accolades that einstein never
lived up to that's the very first
paragraph of michio kakou's new book you
know einstein died with his unfinished
symphony that he couldn't come up with a
theory of everything no despite that
being the name of this channel i think
the gut is almost you know being
overlooked the grand unified theory we
don't understand how the lower energy
forces or the higher energy force are
unified let alone how all four are
unified and who if not you know uh one
of us has the temerity to say that there
has to be a law of quantum gravity what
if there's not so i'll channel my inner
uh you know lee and say you know i don't
believe that there is quantum gravity
because i want to inspire my colleagues
to think harder about it and we've been
going about this for decades now with
little signs of progress um not to say
to stop even string theory which i have
my problems with um uh but the
alternative as they say you know uh the
the string theory is the worst theory
except for all the others uh that could
be true according to whitten
but but i think ultimately the why
questions are the most interesting but
we should be careful not to ask for
motivation i think that evokes teleology
but but also we should be very precise
we should answer all the how questions
as galileo said
measure what is measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so
and as experimentalists lee and i try to
do that
yeah that's a great way to end it put it
i agree
thank you so much to the both of you i
appreciate it and the audience does as
well
my pleasure thank you kurt and thank you
lee i can't wait to be uh together with
both of you guys at some point in the
near future light cone
and all of the links yeah and all of the
links to lee cronin's and brian
keating's work are in the description
thank you
okay thanks guys good job okay so lee i
know i was cutting you off but i know
brian has to go did you want to expand
on what you were saying before
yeah just very quickly so this whole
idea for infinite regress doesn't have
to happen if you haven't if you have an
origin and you have some events to
happen like the the events are random
but as soon as they start to
um
although they're random as they go on in
time they become contingent
because what happens in the future has
some relationship to that in the past
and as long as you don't call screen it
out now
when you start to then create an object
that can then that object can then
actually
interact on the infinite regress don't
go back in the loop but not back to the
beginning and give
some knowledge from the future if you
like to the past
um then that infinite regress is not an
infinite regress it's just selection so
what that means is you have a series of
processes where you make an object so
let's just say you've got some um some
uh chemistry occurring you've got let's
say you have two different streams of
chemistry
and they're random right but then in
each stream so you've got stream a
random stream b random and they're
becoming less random there's some
structure and then stream a
is able to interact with stream b
and to change the reaction
um so it can act back on itself with
more efficiency so that's something that
b can act back on itself yeah and then
you basically then then you get all
sorts of crazy things going because then
a and b become intertwined and mutually
dependent and then that goes up and then
this process of selection
starts to transition and i think that's
the secret but i haven't got there yet
we have seen evidence of this in the
laboratory
and i think this is the answer to the
origin of life but we need to literally
run the experiment put a heavy emphasis
on selection and i'm wondering does sex
selection in your model of life come
prior to reproducing and variation
sounds like variation was there though
in the b a and the b yes so variation
was first that produced selection which
then produced actually
yeah when you have heterogeneity
and then you can get selection
uh and um this kind of variation and and
things
interacting and evolution can actually
still occur on very long time scales and
these in these on these on these
infinite timelines if you like and what
happens is that biology weaponizes
evolution through through autonomous
um reproduction because it like grabs
all those causal chains and can combine
them together in one object and the way
it weaponizes is it basically
replicates the genome stores information
very efficiently from the environment
and then adapts and it can
basically produce lots of attempts
at copying itself with slightly
different causal structures and so why i
see biology is biology is like a
it creates evolution which is an
amplifier for selection
and all the universe is trying to do is
become fitter
i see i i'm having a difficult time
understanding it and i think it's
because i don't know what definition of
cause you're using to say that there was
a first cause that came from something
that was uncaused so i think that's
where my what i'm just saying you've
just got basically is let's think about
symmetry breaking so you've got a highly
symmetrical system and then uh things
interact
and time because the thing is this is
where physicists get really stuck in
that if you've got a time symmetric
system where does the symmetry breaking
come from you have to add something in
an imperfection uh
uh heterosome heterogeneity in
homogeneity
if you have time you break that symmetry
necessarily so there's something really
interesting that we don't understand
about time but um but that's probably
for another podcast
sure man and and the door's open if you
ever want to come back on and talk about
that yeah absolutely yeah yeah it was
really really we you were very patient
with us so it's good because i think
brian brian is a really great debater
and it's you know i've got a lot of
respect for him and what he's doing and
he's really he's his mission is very
good the way he's being precise i'm
learning a lot from him so it was a
pleasure honor indeed to kind of be with
both of you guys and talking yeah so the
honor is all mine man thank you so much
all right you have a nice day see you
take care man and any notes that you
have for me just email me and we can
absolutely we'll communicate there i'll
stay and talk to the audience for a
little bit sorry
impressed by the questions that also uh
that you really had looked up the
assembly theory so i'll ask you about it
sometimes it's really good all right man
take care bye bye
the theory of everyone with tyler
goldstein asks why does he think quantum
mechanics is outside of consciousness
that was my question as well
because you have to presume something
exists outside of consciousness in order
to prove that something exists outside
of it
thank you travis thank you
lj
thank you project malice thank you
sendip thank you corey
thank you phillip
thank you zen jari
one more time there's a podcast coming
out in about two
hours or so with stefan alexander that's
actually a fantastic podcast i was
holding off on publishing that for a
while because i didn't think it was
i think i thought it was incomplete and
i wanted to speak to with stefan some
more
and make it
into a fuller package however as i was
editing it today it seems like wow it's
a wonderful podcast so i expect it to do
well and it's a different podcast it's
an extremely technical podcast
generally when i talk to the physicists
it gets far more technical than
virtually any of the other podcasts and
there's a reason for that i think that's
i think there is a lacking
of that type of content someone wants to
know humphrey wants to know what was it
like spending four hours with chris
langan it was actually longer the
podcast was cut down
hey i like chris chris is a is chris is
he's obstreperous
seemingly but he's a teddy bear
at least to me
so i like chris i can understand why
people
consider him to be abrasive but that's
no but even if he is that's no
well many of the most intelligent people
can be
and it's
that's an ad hominem if one wants to
discount his ideas based on that okay
well
take care everyone thank you so much for
joining
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you